I was so nice to this guy when I talked to him in Pisco's Discord.
I was so insanely nice to him. You have no idea the level of
kid gloves I handled this dude with. And he's sitting here like
laughing at this guy for getting doxed. Like I think I think
given this stuff, given Destiny like bragging about doxing people
all over the place, I do think there's actually a very good reason
to argue that he should be terminated from YouTube. I think he's
mad about getting
This is why like honestly these people this zip zip guy is like
actually a disgusting loser.
>> I think it's esports Batman and Spider go in. >> It's
a game everybody loves me now cuz the anti fights,
>> Sure they do.
>> Well, thanks Josh the Max for the gifted sub. Quarter
mutton tiny at tiny is almost at 4 million. I'm at 2.2 million.
>> What's up?
>> So, just why? >> It's all right. >> You
know, you >> Oh, go ahead.
>> So, why?
>> That's it. Question. >> Like, it's just it's so
funny the double standard's like so obvious just from this. Like,
literally Destiny's like, "Huh, you associate with people who
like associate with people who associate with people who are
mean to me and for that crime.
I have to try to get you doxed and swatted. I have to dox you
so you can maybe be swatted. I have to do that. It's like already
we've reached a level where anybody else who's in any of these
communities is gone. Like instantly. Cut off instantly. Right.
Any person who's not Destiny who's in this like Twitch ball Jason
sphere, they do this. They're gone. Z. >> No. No answer.
You're You're just going to sit here. >> Are you esports
Batman?
>> Yes. He knows. >> Wait, is it? >> Oh my
god. Wait, wait. Is it
sports
>> Oh, you never knew this. Okay, so come on. I got I got
limited time here. Don't waste it. Why?
>> Why? What? >> Why did you do me? >> What?
Me? What?
>> Uh, yes. You
>> would I ever do that?
I I I truly don't understand the Mr. Mutin guy. Okay. I really
actually don't get it at all. Only in so far as like I watch
him. Somebody sent me a clip the other day where he's just like,
"Don't these guys all deserve it?" Like, "Aren't these guys like
not worthy of human consideration at all?" It's like, "Rener
you in this community when esports Batman was around?
Like, didn't you know some of these didn't you know like Wicked
Supreme, Esports Batman? Didn't you know some of these people?
Didn't you know like like I I hate to be like gross, but wouldn't
your like wife had been like friends with a bunch of the people
who had their material
I just don't get how you come in and act like this guy's like
cool and awesome. It's actually really weird. It's super weird
to me. I don't get it. And like I don't want him cancel. I understand
making the money. That's the argument I made. You need need money
and this is a lot of money. But like I actually I just feel like
how do you come in and then you're like actually aggressively
going these people are all scum
knowing Yeah. knowing like
a bunch of the people who had their material leaked like personally
your wife knowing them
is very weird.
I Okay.
>> Like Molina like Molina had her leaked. I don't Okay.
>> Okay. Yeah. Of course. So come on.
Be an adult. own up to it. Why? >> I don't know. I have
to check my logs. >> Oh, you don't even know. Okay. >> Wait,
do you have those logs?
>> Yes, I do. >> Keep asking. >> I don't know
what I'm asking you right now. Why? >> Well, I mean, if
you have evidence of those, how do you feel about those uh emails
that Sabre was shooting around?
>> I don't think that I think they were in good faith,
but I think they were a little bit over the line that I had nothing
to do with them. So
why
I'm not concerned about Sabo? I'm concerned about me. What did
I do
>> You know 8xes are 50 high qual, right? >> Dude,
so weird. It's just so It's so >> Okay, that's what I thought.
Okay. So when I have my call later on this >> Yeah. Like
unironically
and like Moot felt like hard done by by these people. Like he
felt hard done by by a lot of these people. He came back and
he's like just rolling with it.
I It's just It's very weird to me. I don't >> This afternoon
with a couple of people. You just have no reason. >> I
want I want to be on the record about this so that I can say
I've spoken with you directly and asked you why. >> Wait,
are you that mad that people asking you, "Bro, if you care so
much, why don't you do something?"
are you that mad that like you got doxed and your got posted
on Doxin? Are you that mad? You're that mad about it, bro? This
guy
He's lucky. I was so nice to this guy when I talked to him in
Pisco's Discord. I was so insanely nice to him. You have no idea
the level of kid gloves I handled this dude with. Okay. And he's
sitting here like laughing at this guy for getting doxed,
bro. Okay, that's fine. It's crazy. It's like totally crazy to
me. Well, anything that happens going forward,
I want to let you know that it's all thanks to you, buddy. Everything
that happens going forward.
>> Yeah, you lit up. >> Like, I think I think given
this stuff, given Destiny like bragging about doxing people all
over the place, I do think there's actually a very good reason
to argue that he should be terminated from YouTube. Probably
kicked too. He's like openly engaging in a doxing campaign saying
he's doing it. I think he should be banned from both platforms.
I don't think that's wrong to say like that is that is a level
he shouldn't go to prison but he should be banned from both platforms
after >> underneath my butt. So I want to thank you very
much by saying put up or shut up. So I would like to take this
opportunity to recognize
your encouragement and motivation
>> encourage and motivation of of of you.
>> there's a president in here too. >> Do you have
an answer or are you just going to play quick?
Wait, why did you name yourself esports Batman? Do you play video
games? >> My answer is I consider every single person that's
acting
wars are crazy. Hold on. You've already The first sentence you
used was completely moronic, even less.
We haven't doxed anybody. Nobody has been doxed. Literally, nobody
has been doxed. Nobody has sought to aim public harassment at
a specific person that makes them feel uncomfortable in real
life. Nobody has done this, right? It's literally never happened.
You can't call it a war when I'm not doing anything. When I'm
actually I'm not even not doing anything. I am explicitly
saying I disavow. I do not want this. This is the opposite of
what I want. I don't want people doxed. I don't want them pressured
in real life. I don't want that. I want to be able to criticize
people's public public opinions
That's it. Right. So, even from the outset of your sentence here
where you say
doxing wars are crazy. There's no doxing war. Nobody's doxing
back. Nobody's ever doxed back. That's never >> Participating
in that. Uh
>> there was no precipitating docs that made him do this.
There is no doxing back after he does it. He is just doxing people
unilaterally until he like killed his community. It's crazy.
>> Um Discord to be basically the equivalent of a terrorist.
Um I think that you by giving your absolute legal advice, most
of which has been totally incorrect and the other parts have
illustrated you can barely read. Um, I think make you culpable
is basically everything that's going on in that Discord server.
So, suck my dick. >> So, by commenting on the legal case,
you're culpable for anything anybody in that discord server does.
Totally leaving out the fact that nobody knew about Cyber stuff
until like when it got leaked essentially. I knew he'd reached
out to Rose, but I thought that was a totally like one-sided
or uh like back and forth.
And I was like, well, that's weird, but I I don't know. He's
not he's not like using the community to do it. He's not doing
anything crazy. It's like, that's weird. That's [__]
up.
Great. Thank you. That's all I needed to >> Have fun. Be
careful.
>> Wow.
Did their voice defend himself? So,
>> Yeah. I think he started. Just kidding. Are you coming?
Let's go. >> Yeah. So, you left here.
>> Um, yeah. I'm going to the apartments. >> All
right. Let's go. >> Yeah. They kind of dodged the >> He's
suing, I think. Uh, I think what's going to happen
is I would imagine esports Batman and everybody should just go
after Destiny's platforms, right, who are doxing.
Like I think I think I should actually go to like the kickstaff
and be like, "Hey, here's all the evidence of this guy admitting
multiple times to doxing all these people." He makes up that
I've had some hand in it or I've done something back to him or
that something like untoward has happened because of me.
Literally no ev no literally no evidence of it. He's going to
keep doing it. I don't think it's healthy to have him on these
platforms and to advocate for doxing more people on these platforms.
I do think he should be banned. I think he should be demonetized.
I don't think he should be doing this with like I don't think
he should have a platform where he's making money off of this.
It's actually pretty over. Kicks out the exemplars of morality.
I'm pretty sure they're still pretty badly against doxing. >> Does
he play video games? Question.
>> He knew he was going to get owned. That's why he >> implying
that he's going to sue. I >> Oh, I don't. No, I I think
probably just going after the platforms is the good choice. I
think I think YouTube given what has already happened to him
on YouTube would consider terminating him over this 100%. Right.
I never, by the way, don't want anybody to make anything up.
Just want to take the explicit admissions of guilty conduct,
right? And just say, "Yeah, I think I think this YouTube channel
is un like you can't have this." They do moderate offplatform
>> Good for him. >> That was the implication. Yeah.
I don't think you can
>> for getting doxed.
I mean, Kiwi Farms would go down then,
>> Those people are anonymous.
>> Kiwi Farms gets subpoenaed for private for people's
information, but it's very difficult to go after somebody anonymous.
Destiny's not anonymous. I do think, by the way, somebody pointed
this out that uh trying to crowdfund a lawsuit to go after him
for this for harassment would just be good on its
Um there are harassment laws that you can sue under. friends
$3. >> I don't mind chilling and waiting a bit to see how
things go, >> but Modmail doesn't work since I'm not in
the server, though. Just an FYI.
>> Okay. Uh, I'll try to figure it out at some point. Yeah,
it's a little Yeah, exactly. He's He's admitting like bad intent
on the Pisco stream. He's admitting bad intent. He's literally
saying, "I did it." He's posting it himself. He's not denying
it anywhere. Perfectly happy to take culpability for it. I do
think there are real ways you could sue somebody for this where
you can prove their specific like malice.
He's explicitly doing this to try to like destroy my business,
right? That's got to be there's got to be a bunch of there. No,
that's what he's admitting to here, right? He's talking about
destroying my community, destroying the uh the Jtock Discord
server. That's like going after my business, right? I'm sure
there's a hundred different ways a lawyer could think of how
to sue somebody over this, but we'll see. Who knows? He actually
got that mad that everyone was telling him, "Bro, you obviously
don't care about this. Shut the up." >> I think he's mad
about getting doxed. This is why like honestly these people,
this Zip Zip guy is like actually a disgusting loser. Like having
him in your community is a huge indictment of your community.
I think you
like the the parasites who are like, "Oh, no, you should be able
to dox people." There's no there's no large difference between
DGG these people and who will who will advocate for totally cataclysmic
negative action from Destiny with no reason. No, they do the
defensive doxing thing. They can't prove anybody is culpable
for the the doxes they're putting out. Right. The people they
dox aren't culpable for the things that they're upset about at
all. Destiny is directly culpable for what esports Batman is
upset about. You see the >> No, I do care, guys. I do care.
>> I He's so lucky. He's so lucky. I didn't uh
I didn't watch this first. Holy [__] All this talk
and he said he was neutral and wick. Yeah, he's just a liar.
They're just liars, dude. It's nuts. I'm going to make so many
calls later. >> Well, I mean, they came in so aggressive.
I thought that it was like a troll. I was like, why? I was like,
>> yeah, I didn't realize.
>> Uh there's another opport there's another possibility
here. It's possible that Mutin is like just concerned that by
sitting outside Destiny's sphere of influence, by not directly
operating in favor of him, he will be put on the terrorist watch
list at some point in the near future. Right. His wife did retweet
that Substack. Has Pichu apologize for retweeting Pixie substack?
Hey, Mr. Moon. Has has Pikachu apologized for that? I feel like
she should probably start cooking up Pixie should apologize for
the Substack, right? Shouldn't Pikachu apologize for retweeting
it and amplifying it and amplifying all of Destiny's victims?
That was probably a wrong thing to do,
>> I thought there was somebody I thought it was a voice
trainer was gonna do. I have to stop watching this. I I I'm going
to skip forward to the spider bit.
>> Is it for just like like this just like um disagreements
or just like or or what? Like >> Yeah, just because they
disagree with my opinion. I think >> that must be it, bro.
>> Yeah, I think it's because they basically been long
like long-term stalking and harassing me and people around me
for Yeah. about a year now. It's been I think it's pretty relentless.
It's pretty insane. And when it's got to the >> Oh, wait.
Is it harassing in the same way that you harass Hassan? Was Hassan
correct in everything he said that you guys like follow Hassan?
Your community watches him constantly a logs everything he says
in his Discord. Constantly provides it to other content creators
so that Hassan could be further harassed. Is that harassment?
I'm like I'm like
doubleA baseball version of the Yankee. Okay. Like Destiny's
the Yankees. DG's the Yankees of harassing someone in the exact
way he's describing. Like right. I'm like double A baseball.
I like there's a whole other level of that I could take it to
before I get anywhere near Destiny's League. Okay.
How am I materially different from what they do?
Is that lying about being harassed? He's describing what you
you could say cuz harassment is just subjective basically. You
could say this is harassment, right?
But I'm I'm telling you it is far less than what Dan and Destiny
have done to Hassan. It's like 1 1,000th of what D and Destiny
have done to Assan.
How many people is Assan doxed?
Quick question. How many people is doxed? Oh, it's like zero.
>> Where that Saba guy is literally bragging about emailing
like a victim in my court case and is and everybody in that server
is like clapping along. >> What is she What is she a victim
of? What is she a victim of? >> And laughing at it is Yeah,
I think it's I'm good on that. Chief, >> I I would want
anybody if anybody could argue. Like, if anyone hears that argument,
if you're watching this on YouTube and you want to go back to
it, bro, step in. Like, I understand why some people might not
like it, but I just don't get why anyone acts like it's like
so evil. Like, it was just clearly like a totally evil act. And
then cuz I would accept if like somebody from my community want
to come in and go like, "I can't morally accept this at all that
that like Cyber is allowed to stay." I would understand you're
applying a standard, right? But it's DJers who are totally disingenuously
applying a standard they don't believe it. Crazy. >> You
said you had a couple questions. That was one. >> Oh yeah.
Uh like would you ever like uh we came to the bridge with the
JCO or something or what or no? Or just like >> maybe if
he's like suicidal and he needs like supplies, but otherwise
no.
>> that's that's true. That's just that's
>> Um do you think um
Shut the G? I [__] hate you. Do you think um you
kind of overreacted of like by like doxing a couple of people
inside the Jag community a little bit?
>> No, they I don't think they have like I'm I'm not trying
to like downplayers, but like I don't think they cause you like
physical harm, right? I don't think
>> Okay. I don't think I caused them physical harm, did
I? >> Not that I'm aware of. No. >> No. Well, then
we're good. Triple ass. I I don't think I don't think like
>> Spider is so
uh he's just so >> I don't think I don't think like this
having disagreements like you know like them getting doxed though
low key >> you what
>> I I don't think like having disagreements over you know
certain reason or certain situations
like justify um them getting docked like >> wow that's
a brave position. You don't think disagreeing with people on
the internet is reason to get docks? That's a good one dude.
True. I know. Sure. >> Then why are they doxing? >> Okay,
so this fat won't actually
this guy. Oh, this guy. I disavow. I apologize for what I just
said, but holy [__] this guy.
Why is he Why is he going to say that this happening? It's not
happening. It's not happening. It's literally not happening.
Show me any evidence of this happening. Any evidence that I had
anything to do with it that I didn't disavow it. When this guy
had bad happen to him, when people would say, "Oh, this guy's
a loser. You should go after him." I always defended him every
time him and his wife and now he's going to totally lean into
this cuz he can make money. You're a [__] loser.
You have no idea what you're talking about. You can't actually
you can't actually show anything you're going to allege and you
go and suck the of this predator because you are a fat loser.
Okay? You and your wife have
you are insubstantial
soulless drains. Okay? And the reason you're back in Destiny's
community is because society has deemed you as such and you have
no other way to make money. Okay, good luck
when when everything when when everything's said and done. Good
luck. >> Jake, this is triggering. >> I get triggered
because I actually gave this guy the benefit of the doubt so
many times. And I do that every single time. Every single time.
Okay. And I just get shown what people these people are. Every
single time I give the benefit of the doubt to Arerodite. I give
the benefit of the doubt to counterpoints. I give the benefit
of the doubt to mutin and his wife. Every single time I'm the
for acting like these people have a single
ounce of calcium left in their spines every single time. It's
such a joke.
>> The ro family check where the I don't know. I know I
don't know where to get the information the rose information
from that. >> I didn't know that. I just You're telling
me now for the first time. But I haven't seen like
maybe my blind [__] I haven't seen like the J community
like docs like any other like DG though. >> They don't
need to. Every doc is posted on Kiwi Farm. So they actively collaborate
with then why would they dox anybody just >> way actively
collaborate with? Okay. Show me active collaboration. Where's
the active collaboration? Careful. His wife isn't. His wife gets
on the streams. What the [__] are you talking about?
That'd be stupid. Do you have like this is the one who gave the
docs information of Rose to Kiwi Farms. How are these people
so brain damaged? How are these people so brain dead? She talks
about you. She hops on the stream. She's part of the content.
Moon's doing content on this every day. You think they don't
understand? You think they don't talk about it? What do you think?
No, no, no, no, no. I don't think, by the way, all that said,
I'm angry because I give these people the benefit of the doubt.
I go, "Oh, well, here's like a totally innocent thing and they're
just going to make their money and they're then they're going
to move on, right?
They're just going to make their money, but they're not going
to get like involved. And then this guy helps spread lies, and
I'm like, "Oh, actually,
this loser." No, Pikachu didn't do the same thing. But [__]
this loser. Okay.
Uh, also, obviously, same rules as always apply. You don't go
after these people. You don't talk to them. You don't like reach
out to them. You don't do Okay. Obviously,
I'm venting because I just I continually try to give people the
benefit of the doubt in this area and they fail me in in like
um totally like immoral ways every single time. I'm just like,
"Do the right thing, dude. Do the [__] right thing.
Just call it out. Just call out the behavior." And they're all
It's like It's just the Trump thing. It's like a cult. It's crazy.
>> Any like confirmation that like
Nope. I'm too stupid. I made that all up. They're too smart for
me. I can't. I think I just made all of that up. >> He's
literally smiling. This ugly fat is
Look at his face. Look at his face with this disgusting pubic
hair on his chin. >> Gross, dude.
>> Do you have any confirmation that I do any of them?
>> Uh,
I seen I seen some screenshots from the in the
>> You sure?
>> Literally.
Do you do you have proof that Yeah. Everybody's proof? Yes.
To show face to do all this? No, I don't. This man is ugly in
a vacuum. He is disgusting in a vacuum. He is melted ice cream
in a vacuum. Okay. I can say whatever the I want.
>> N you're mean, bro. >> I'm not meaning. They're
fake. That's
>> N you're mean, bro. You >> think I would dock
somebody, bro? That's like the same as somebody. >> Bro,
you're a liar right now. >> Are you serious? Positive
100%. >> Shrimple ass. Shrimple.
>> Shrimple ass. >> When when these people have no
skill set by which they can operate in the world and they're
trying to convince you, okay, some year three three years down
the line that they didn't really know what Destiny was doing.
They did they didn't really know. He like kind of convinced.
They're just lying. Okay. They're just lying. Everybody in that
orbit just lying the whole time.
They're all lying. They're a bunch of liars.
I still have things I could talk about with these people that
would just be super uncomfortable. Super uncomfortable conversations
that I keep to myself cuz I'm uh >> Wait, can I ask you
something? Have y'all seen Jacob dox anyone? Well, besides all
Rose, I don't know those >> Besides that one.
>> Oh, no. Destiny is the one who dox Rose. Destiny is
the one who dox Rose. We didn't dox Rose. Caba talked to Rose.
didn't publish any of that information publicly obviously, >> right?
The victim. >> Yeah. I mean I mean like I mean like that's
kind of weird. I don't know. You should like email like the family.
It's kind of word. Um
shmple
as my friend. >> Let's go to that location.
>> I haven't seen like >> Oh, it's not information
that would go against Destiny.
So people who prop him up.
People prop him up.
What do >> you mean like other examples of like doxing
like you or >> spider? Spider is just like so low IQ. It's
very funny. >> At this point, actually, I just I don't
care what happens to any of these communities. Like, Peace Co
included. I think that all you guys are weird and need to be
wiped from the internet. I think it's all like gotten way out
of hand. I'm like, at this point, I don't give a [__]
about any of it. Shremble.
>> Coer, just a quick update. Destiny had to go over some
of these logs and stuff in real time and couldn't do it. Hold
on. Let me go find this real quick. Let me find out what I sent
real quick. Real quick, real quick. Where are these logs?
Sorry. I also I regret saying the slur. Okay, I regret saying
the slur not because it wasn't appropriate, but because
I regret how it affects other people. Okay,
the logs. Yeah, he basically got like confronted on these. And
he goes, there's no evidence here that I that I kept. It's like
this is by the way like the third time he's being asked about
it.
Like, bro, you let your you let me know your you still have videos
saved your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was underage.
You still have them. Do you see how this is? That's like on its
face just obvious you have. It's really up that you're telling
me this. And Destiny doesn't go, "No, I don't have you misunderstood
me."
He goes, "I don't even know 100% of her age is legitimately less
than 18 when these were taken." If you don't have, why are you
like saying why it might not be? Yeah. What are these when these
were taken? Cuz he also said, "Oh, I wasn't talking about like
a video." Wait, what would it be? Why would it be a problem if
she was legitimately under 18 when quote unquote these were taken?
And then number two, I'm pretty sure I still have an obligation
to preserve stuff related to my court case. I've talked about
this with my lawyer already, specifically with regards to the
Rose stuff. Oh.
Oh, to be honest, what we should do is actually start a Twitter
campaign to get this in the hands of JD Vance. I think that's
the appropriate play. Start clipping this stuff up. Start showing
the logs. Get somebody to post a video. Get that blowing up on
YouTube. Okay. Of all of this stuff with the explicit idea of
getting JD Vance, getting it in JD Vance's hands. Hey JD, this
is like open and shut, buddy. This is open and shut. Cash would
[__] it up. Oh no. Well, we'll wait until Cash is
fired and then we'll we'll re-evaluate. Okay, that is a good
point though.
JD sucks. Give it to Don Jr. What kind of excuse could he possibly
say? My guess he misremembered and thought he had but realized
HE DIDN'T. NO, THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A BETTER EXCUSE. COER. He
sat there trying to explain how none of these messages mean one
iota that he retains. That would have been A GOOD LIE. THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A WAY BETTER LIE. He actually just tried to gaslight
everybody and say that these logs don't mean anything. The these
are not the logs you're looking for. He tried to do a Jedi mind
trick. Okay, that's the sad thing. And three, if something were
to come of this, I don't know if I'd want to wipe everything
and not have something to turn over to the authorities.
As in he's a white hat, guys. White hats. White hats enjoyer.
Okay, guys. What if the What if the cops do want to look into
this? Shouldn't I hold on to the child? Like, they're all pertaining
to if Willie was correct. Like, Willie is saying this is C. And
he's like, well, I don't know for sure. It's And I do want to
I do want to retain it just in case. And he went with no no no.
I don't I don't actually I really, really, really don't actually
I didn't mean this was at all. It's crazy.
if hype. Dude, the best the funniest part about this is Willie
is like so Willy's like so low IQ that the Destiny community
managed to like sigh up him into thinking he might have gotten
this wrong.
That's like almost funnier than Destiny's defense is that Willie
is like so low IQ. He's so without his own internal monologue
that he was convinced that he was actually wrong for this for
like posting this for being upset about it for calling like he
convinced himself he was wrong. Like he might be wrong.
It's like dude that is crazy.
You could absolutely do that to Willie. Yeah, I do believe that.
Yeah, I think you could totally convince Willie if you had enough
Twitter clout. You could convince Willie that it's flat like
in a day. in a day and a half tops. Anyway,
it's some goofy action. Okay. Some very goofy action.
>> Wait, Spider, are you guys way too comfortable talking
[__] and being weird? Is stalking, harassing people?
>> It's kind of weird. >> So, Spider, are you a loner
box editor?
>> No, I'm the clipper. The clip guy.
>> Okay.
Uh, somebody said to ask, "How do you feel about spreading bad
empanada dog saying water box?" >> That's pretty dog [__]
happens to pretty weird.
>> Oh.
Oh, interesting. Okay.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> J just something I wanted to ask. That's
>> I mean, like I don't have a stake in this.
What's a observer, bro?
I'm I'm looking at from both sides. Okay. Oh, both sides.
Neutral. Both sides. Very
Did Willie Mack walk back the video? No, he said I think he said
something along the lines of
>> um if I was wrong I'll apologize when everything's said
and done but like I something along those lines. >> Very
neutral.
>> I think so. >> I have no beef for any side neutral.
>> I don't >> I don't think like am I
trying to like do that
>> you think bad wasn't I think bad but was posting doc's.
He was posting like he would like false sue somebody, get a false
police report filed and then he would publish the information.
That's oxy. Come on, ma'am. Come on, man. >> I get it.
Maybe because of like what they say is kind of maybe it might
be unhinged about like the whole like court, but I don't think
it's like justified docs, you know, like what if she thinks zip?
>> What do you think? Zip zip.
>> Wait, sorry, I didn't hear what was the
>> Do you think that like what Destiny said was like Yeah,
you know what?
Okay. of like if they disagree if they
uh say unhin [__] or disagree with me on like uh
on like the whole court situation or any other stuff in general
they deserve to get dogs like you don't think that's a little
bit crazy >> no that's what he said
>> I don't think that's what he said at all that anybody
who disagrees with dogs I think you're right that you think that's
what he said >> he said anybody agreeing in those discords
right sorry he didn't even say that he said anybody be associating
those escores getting doxed. >> It's mo voice changer.
Uh oh, >> I might be.
Could I
could be? Maybe. Who >> I think basically his opinion is
like all these anti fan communities have gotten so out of hand
and crazy that he just doesn't give what happen give a [__]
what happens anymore.
>> But like doesn't that give like more >> Oh my
god. Doesn't that justify them? Doesn't that make what they're
saying true and right?
I mean, again,
there's a reason Destiny went to doxing instead of just pulling
up clips of me and saying where I was wrong and why I was wrong,
right? There's a reason he went to doxing instead of doing that.
Well, he cut against the entirety of the Ke's manifesto to do
it. >> Actually, no. Actually, you know, actually, you
know, one time I was like raping this girl and she was like,
"Oh my god, stop." And then she hit me and I was like, "When
you smack me as I'm Doesn't that kind of justify me doing this?
I'm kind of proving my point when I I'm trying to do one time
I was stabbing this guy with a knife like 20 times and he punched
me in the nose and I was like when you punch me is that kind
like justify me stabbing you
>> like that?
>> No, it's not like that. Um >> Oh, there's nothing
like that. Okay.
>> God, it's unfortunate cuz I again I pulled away. I wasn't
covering this stuff as much
and this guy just had to start going after people again in the
Discord. He's like just made it clear that it's my community
or his community. Probably both in the end. But
if that's if he wants people like motivated to like
get justice for this as in like actually go to some form of of
authority, report it, seek whatever monetary or like whatever
penalties we can put on him. Again, through official means through
these platforms, through uh the law. I'm definitely going to
pursue the law thing now. I I thought it was pointless, but I
don't think it's pointless. I think it actually has a purpose
now. So, I'm glad I'm glad that some people have brought it up.
>> Eat rapology gum.
>> My bad. >> It probably gives like Jac
>> How? What?
>> Probably gives like Jacock and his community more ammo.
No. Or
>> I'm sorry, I couldn't hear you. I was a robot up. >> It
probably gives JC and his community more ammo.
>> Really? I thought a few people left the server once
people started getting docks. That's what I saw. >> Like
just kind of giving away what his actual motive is, right? >> Curious.
I also know that certain people were given immunity >> from
doxing. >> Oh, like who? >> Cuz they were engaged
in bad behavior.
>> You weren't banned in the JAC meeting.
>> They were what? >> You weren't banned in the JAC.
>> The [__] is immunity from
>> being doxed?
Oh, it's not immunity. You guys are the ones who aren't operating
in like a liberal way, right? It's not immunity. You have just
decided as the dictator who's shooting people in the head who
say anything bad about you that you're going to some cute girl
in the head. That's all that's happened here. >> By people
who would want to do Jay sucks for members. >> I don't
really understand what you're
I mean, I have 52K this run. >> I've got 44 lucky. >> Yeah.
Can you restate it? >> A few Yeah. A few people were given
immunity from being >> he's saying that basically uh so
they're explicitly trying to dox people in my community to try
to get people to leave my community
and
they are explicitly
dude
they're explicitly saying well but actually like if you argue
on behalf of Destiny in that discord maybe you could maybe you
could stay and just like not you get immunity you get immunity
I guess apparently I've never heard of this concept immunity
from the doxing
we've given immunity to a couple members >> for being in
the Jubile server. >> Oh, okay. >> So, it wasn't
just it wasn't just
>> I don't think that's >> I'm ready to >> and
train out. [__] up. >> Let's go.
>> Is your inventory full? >> Bro, what?
>> Oh, like you can hold a lot of stuff or a little stuff?
>> You can hold like five things, six
>> Sorry. Go ahead. >> No, I'm just listening to
Zip Zip. >> What is it? >> Some bullshitter got [__]
for getting knocked. So, >> yeah. that the robot. >> But
did the people who who got docks
or whoever got immunity did crazy or something or what? Um >> people
immunity did that's why they
Don't catch. Don't hit them with
hit. Simple as
>> Whatever, bro. >> Uh, what did they think?
>> Uh, yeah. He's um, but that's fine.
apparently they learned nothing from Israel. Okay.
pushing people until they have like no other choice but to like
do whatever they can to survive. Usually not a good idea.
Okay.
And again, I'm going to stick to the rules. I'm going to report
him in the ways I can to the places I can.
I've never done it before, by the way. I've never reported him
for anything. But like this is just clear. It's like clear what
we're doing here, right? It's crazy.
that doesn't work. Um,
I've already got a couple DMs. It's good. Whatever this is, I
He is changing people's minds, right? Being this brazen about
it, he is changing people's minds. I'm already getting DMs. Okay,
stop vague posting. I'm getting DMs from people who work at platforms
and are like, "Hey, I work here. I do this. Um, if you want to
put something together, that kind of thing." Which is good cuz
that's actually the thing that kind of prevented me from before
from doing it before, right? was not having like contacts in
>> Hassan. If he spreads the docks of Lorok or uh other
people from PE progressive victory, does that justify him getting
>> I don't really give a [__] about. Okay.
I mean like I don't care if he gets dogs. I don't care. >> Hassan
Hassan. I mean like technically he didn't like he kind of like
I don't give a [__] I don't care. So >> it's
it we can we can do Kasan for doxing loner box and uh other people
>> Yeah for him.
>> Okay. And uh JTO JTO supporting doxers
them being part of his community and
>> no evidence of this at all. Certainly not at a level
that could to justify anything like this. Right. So, I'll never
say that there's no never been anybody doxed in my community
because there's not a single online community where that's the
case. Like seriously, why are we why are we pretending that this
is a bar anybody can meet? This again is just a careful manifesto
standard. I can't prevent anonymous people from doing random
[__] in my community. I can moderate it, right? I
can moderate it if it happens. If you are aware of it happening
and you want to report it to me, I will take action. I have rules
against it. You literally get banned automatically if you post
links to Kiwi Farms in my Discord.
Remember when he cut off Nick because some guy who's streaming
to Uncosy to 75 guys said to report Mr. Girl. Oh, we're way past
that. We're way past that. Coer. Yeah, I know. He's a total He's
just a total liar, man. >> Being posted his community also
justifies his community getting dogs. >> I mean like some
like specific doxers like who like like who do like who? >> The
the whole community they they support it just same way Husan
supports the docking. >> Yeah, but like doin who? Like
who? Destiny what your the DG? >> Yeah. Yeah, sure. DJs
people involved with the case. >> Do people in have like
the Jaw community um doxed them or
>> or did do the people you said DG got doxed by the Jaw
community? Like I'm saying I'm asking like does DGG currently
have like screenshots of like the Jaw community doxing him or
what?
>> They support it same way Hassan supports about other
doxing people.
>> Yeah. He says no that's actually totally false. Totally
disavow doxing. Totally disavow that puts somebody in fear of
their real life safety. Right. Anything like that you there's
obviously a huge gap between you just being like this guy's a
fat loser and straight up doxing somebody trying to post any
info you can to get them hurt. Right. Like obviously there's
a massive difference. Obviously >> support I'm asking like
who like like is there any screenshots from the DG
>> having screenshots of the Jaw community?
>> Uh I think there's uh evidence that they support them
not that they directly do it but same way Hassan doesn't.
>> So evidence they support them. So that's a totally subjective
standard you've invented. Now show me the evidence that they
support that we support doxing. I actually, dude, it's crazy.
Bears repeating the Kevl manifesto where he talks about KF getting
undue hate and hints at Doc's bin. Yeah. Okay, hold on. So, is
this going to be the website zero section? We can look over right
now. We should watch this whole thing again on stream. Think
that what happens is, so here's kind of what happens. Kiwi Farms
is the most visible site on the internet that does harassment,
but there's a lot of other things that exist in the background
that are arguably responsible for more.
And none of those websites are ever brought up because there's
no glory in chasing those websites. People want to slay the dragon.
They want to get Kiwi Farms. Um, but Kiwi Farms basically ends
up taking the fall or getting the blame for literally everything.
Even >> Wow. So, are they like not that bad?
>> you saying my Discord's like dox? >> Even though
a lot of the stuff like the Uber Eats hacks, like the swattings
and the doxings, like there was that one swatting that didn't
even happen. The person emailed me and told me that they called
the police. Um, I just don't think it's right that like Kiwi
Farms is getting like the blame for every single bad set on the
internet. >> No,
tipped $5. >> Greetings J. Le Kadima Achi Koha Shell Arts
Ha Nich.
>> Thank you very much for the five. Ben Shapiro
should get nuked off the internet for doxing. Um, fine, but like
it has to be for doxing. like um it can't be made up other you
can't attribute and like so like you can't take things that they
didn't do
and attribute it to the person you want to hurt.
Like you can't you can't try to go for like one specific person
and then take actions from other sources and attribute it to
that person with no link, no obvious causal link at all. like
you're kind of applying liberal principles here where somebody's
like innocent until proven guilty and you need to actually have
a causal link between them and some harm before you can actually
go after them like that. The problem that I have too is that
Serenti like Serenti obviously knows in the background that this
other site exists because she's trying to get other people not
to talk about it and then she's constantly and consistently blaming
Kiwi Farms for stuff that the other website is doing. Dude, it's
crazy how badly he just became Keles like in every possible way.
like down to Keel's obsession with trying to dox other people
after it happened to him. Like the exact same thing, bro. He's
got to get that boob job before he runs out of money. Okay?
He's got to get those triple D's before he runs out of money.
Just saying.
You don't want to you don't want to risk you don't want to risk
one of those airate bots jobs. Okay. >> But um yeah,
for future people to reach out to you directly that might now
be concerned about future leaks, is there any particular reason
you leaked the Bob posting messages? Um cuz I think that her
and um Keville are sketchy as both of them. So what do we learn
about the DIY HRT site? Ke's lying isn't a new phenomenon. Clay
was open about homebrew as was on the site itself.
All right. All right,
dude. It's crazy.
That's It's so wrong to attribute these things to kiwi farms.
Even Kiwi farms when they didn't do them. It's so up that you
can't You're going after them, but not for their real behavior.
Oh, what is Destiny doing? going after my community, but not
for their behavior. Not anything. The Kyla peace out. I don't
know. She took like a month off again, but she's been DMCAing
Riyle. So, I assume she's there doing >> that whole sec.
>> I think she's if she would just like reach out and be
like, "Hey, cuz I don't know what her problem is with the content,
like Riyle's content." But she's been DMCAing Riyle and being
like, "I'm going to keep DMCing you unless you take all the content
of me down." So, that's cool.
But
I do think
it might have to do with the thumbnails.
I feel like if you just reach out like the thumbnails are up,
don't do the thumbnails. I would get it, right? Like I I would
I would say Ry, you shouldn't do the thumbnails. Ry, don't do
the don't do the thumbnails. I get that everyone likes fat Arerodite.
They think it's funny, but don't do the thumbnails. It's kind
of it's mean, but like if it's like the the the content itself
is transformative and if Aerodite is like that concerned about
it. If we're going to do Aerodyite content in the future, we'll
just clip it, right? Like I'm fully committed to doing Aerodyite
content whenever whenever she says something. Fully committed
to doing it at any point in the future. Okay, Ry, stop posting
a unedited. No, no, no, no, no, no. She gets edited and it gets
made to look fat and it's like I get how that would be frustrating.
I get it. I would not extend that to probably anybody else. But
for every day, she's like described body image issues like whatever.
Could do not do fat. But like you can't DMCA transformative content
or if she's going to. I do believe
it's it's time to actually stand up business on that. Okay, you
should.
I can't tell Ra what to do. You should >> Felt like a shot
with no tracer. Well, Chloe says that she's never >> It's
like the same that happened to Beckett with KP though, right?
It's like the exact same. >> Plugged anything related to
homebrew. She's spamming it at me right now in DMs. She's never
had anything to do with >> Oh, why am I still watching
this? We don't care about this. I don't think I care about this
anymore either. I'll watch it till Spider >> people, but
he supports about other indoxing people and he spreads the >> Like
what? Kiwi Farms like Jac supports like the JS community supports
like Kiwi farmers or or what?
>> They they share the thread. They talk about the like
the epic meme >> that he's making things up. There might
be references to Blav, but I mean Blav has honestly
like wreaked havoc in that community almost as much as he's wreaked
it in
So like but yeah, you get autobed for the links and you have
been for months and months and months from before Destiny was
like saying that we were like Kiwi farmers or something. That's
so crazy, man. >> Who dogs people, they support them. They
post like screenshots from there. >> This is just not This
is like explicitly not true. Like he's just explicitly lying
again. And then they go, "Oh, well, you closed your Gen Chat."
Because somehow, and I don't know how this happened with Destiny
advocating uh mass harassment on my community, but somehow people
were getting reported for literally
everything,
right? Like literally I got reported for saying, "Uh, oh man,
Vos review today." question mark that got reported for child
safety.
So, I just closed all of the old general chat because I think
the messages get tagged in some way that they like were said
when the chat wasn't 18 plus. So, I switched the chat to 18 plus.
I archived the old gen chat and then I put a new gen chat in
cuz I didn't want people to keep getting banned for nothing.
But like that's a response to legitimate harassment. So >> they
they like uh giggle when someone uh gets uh harassed by them.
They celebrate whenever some one gets >> Example example
example. Okay.
>> There was the laughing at the Rose thing, but that was
laughing. I laugh because Destiny doxed her himself and proved
that he'd been a minor been exchanging material with a minor
through a proxy.
Right. That's
that's what actually happened. someone gets knocked like a like
like from like the DG committee or like any other content creator.
>> Yeah, like uh like uh people around
>> But to be fair, that's not because people are psyched
Rose got doxed. What that is is Destiny saying that it's a Kiwi
Farm skitso theory, that she's 17, that she's a minor, that everybody's
lying who says it. Right. That was Destiny who said that. Uh
everybody's making that up. When they reference this girl, they
don't care. They They're just making that up. It's a lie. It's
a lie. It's a lie. And then he's he literally doxes her because
I don't know why
apparently to find out who leaked this was what he said today.
that cuz that makes sense when you have her name and her face
in her school and her major. That definitely makes sense. But
regardless of how stupid that is,
he docked her himself and proved she was 17. Proved that she
was a minor when she was exchanging material with him. We don't
actually believe it. This was an elaborate elaborate catfish.
Do we? So, it could have been a catfish in that I might be led
to believe or I might believe that the solo person did the lion
share of this messaging.
Maybe, maybe,
maybe.
I don't really believe it because like I said, I just don't think
there's any way where
Yeah. I I don't see any universe
where she is taking like a picture of some dude that looks like
Destiny to send to him,
right? Yeah. It doesn't really matter for Destiny's actions.
Sure. But I don't believe it's some elaborate catfish. No, it
changes nothing for Destiny's culpability as we discussed with
that guy earlier. >> People like Dan Hitch Dan's wife.
>> well, hold on. It also the fact that she was 17 also
totally explodes the implied consent argument, right?
He can't argue implied consent because Pixie knew Molina might
see it and so therefore she knew a bunch of people might see
it. There's no way he thought he had implied consent for an 18
so-called 18-year-old sex worker that he'd known for a week that
he just started DMing.
Right?
There is no universe where he could argue that he thought he
had implied consent in that case. And nobody will ever hold this
guy. They just never hold him accountable for his previous lies.
Right? So he's lied the whole time. The whole timeline is just
nothing but lies. He He tried to dox me. He posted a bunch of
other docs
before Rose was doxed, before any of the things that he's saying
justifies the docks. And now he's reversing it. Right? He's he's
running backwards in time
and using actions that he couldn't have possibly known about,
that he had no idea about, right? That hadn't yet come to pass
and he's justifying the previous doxing. It makes no sense. And
this fat ugly loser just sits here smirking and >> Yeah.
Wife got docks on Q farms and like what Jason can be celebrated
or
to show. >> Nope. And I don't think Dan would even I don't
think Dan would say that. I think I think Dan would say that
that is wrong. And he knows that's wrong. Dan knows for a fact
that as much of a problem as I have with him, I've explicitly
never said anything bad about his wife or his kids and I'd said
it's insane. Even though I think he is a person who wants to
dox people, who looks to dox people, who's facilitated doxing
people, even in spite of that, I've said it's insane to think
about going after his wife for kids. That's nuts.
Okay. Okay. Dan himself would never say this is true. Case in
point, I can still talk to Dan if I need to.
>> I didn't know that. I just You're telling me? >> I'm
pretty sure there screenshots of that as well. Yeah. So like
>> you can probably go on KA farms. You can probably go
on KA farms and find that if you want, but I don't know. >> No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Is there any reason to believe
that I had anything to do with that? That my Discord had anything
to do with that? Because here's the other thing they don't ever
acknowledge is that Destiny decided to have a personal match
with the number one Alog, the number one doxer on Kiwi Farms
that he totally got rid of him, by the way.
totally emasculated by this guy repeatedly.
But Destiny made that a rivalry by himself by referencing that
guy by bringing up his posts, bringing up his theories, saying
he was a loser, saying he was a skitso, constantly
constantly interacting with his Alogs in a way that would upset
them and make them more deranged.
Right? I had nothing to do with that. I didn't make him do that.
I would have told him not to do that. He's the one who did it.
And then he blames me for when that guy docks people around him.
It's insane. Say his name. Why not? Well, I could say it's Blav.
Yeah, we all know it's Blav, right? Everybody knows it's Blav.
Blav gets referenced in Destiny.
Destiny's brought Blav up multiple times on his stream.
But I'm saying Destiny has like literally turned it into an ego
match with this guy. And he got blown the out by this guy, by
the way, because he kept saying, "Oh, you're wrong. You're you're
you're skitso. You could never find this person. They're 18."
And then he lost, right? That guy did dox that person eventually
with Destiny's help and proved she was 17.
Like sad, really sad reality that he turned it into that. But
that person hated Destiny. That that match started before I was
somebody who was against Destiny. The reason I didn't go on anything
else is because I was concerned that that guy was going nuts
and doxing everybody.
That was when I was friends with these people. They offered me
to come on on anything else to get flown down to Miami. Okay.
And go on their podcast. And I said, "No, thank you. That that
black guy is going insane. I'm not, dude. I'm not putting my
head up right now. It's GTA five stars out here. That Okay, I'm
not stick my head up. I'm going to keep to myself. No thank you.
No thank you. No thank you." I think Well, he said he wanted
to prove that they couldn't dox her or something, right? Yeah.
Who knows? Lab saved you from Epstein's Island. Well, Epstein
Island, maybe. Dude, it's like
But none of this matters. None of these people engage with honesty,
with reality. They don't engage with anything. They're just losers.
Oh my
>> Why you're trying now to Are you trying to spread the
dog's further by asking me >> That's like a loner box guy,
by the way. Spider doesn't even like me. Spider Lily doesn't
like me at all.
>> No. Who the [__] am I in the J discord,
>> How do we get out of here? He say he say he's not to
Are you trying to spread the dog's further by asking me this?
>> No. Who the [__] am I in the J discord,
>> How do we get out of here?
is in the Discord all the time. Spider's literally a member of
the Discord. >> I know. I don't know what you think. I'm
assume like roller j, bro. Like
>> nah, spider's a big big timer. Big
>> I like added I I literally put a big message like tagging
somebody who used to be in the Discord and left because Destiny
was doxing everybody everybody. I went DJ be aware this is a
JSTAR on the run. Be aware Jstalker on the run. Don't let him
get and then I had to delete it cuz I thought it was a little
too on the uh a little too on the nose. I was like, "Oh, if they
dox him, I'm going to feel like horrified." >> Yeah, I'm
just saying that uh same same logic that uh justifies Hassan
getting door logic should you should apply to Jto community.
They have the same model. >> Uh so he says this with no
proof of anything he's saying, right? They just repeat the same
lie over and over again. I didn't say enough on Wick. I should
have said that they are too scared. They can't prove anything
about this. They literally have no evidence that they could hold
me to in any way. The thing they brought up with Riyle, Riyle
got banned for that, by the way. Riyle got banned for that even
though
he was like drunk and I was like, "Okay." Like, and then he apologized
and and it got worked out. I think I think lots of the mods didn't
like him after that, but like it got worked out.
And again, by the way, never been the argument that it's like
just, you know, that two random lovers can't say each other's
names in the gen chat. Okay, that did happen. But
nobody's ever complained about that. The complaint is harassing
and doxing people around Destiny, which has never happened.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean like if I see if I hear if I have
like if there's like proof of the J community like celebrating
docs like celebrating like um D's wife getting docks then I don't
really have like any sympathy towards the committee or uh
>> You know what I think the problem is >> wait real
quick walk. We're going to do the raptors up. Okay. I think somebody
went in cuz I see them. >> This guy's gonna This guy's
about to show that his brain is about as attractive as his face.
Give it a >> I'm not googling any though. I think the problem
is is that Discord allows any random to create a server without
any barrier to entry. >> We're not doing rockets. Run,
run, run. >> Don't get rocked. >> Uh my Discord has
4,500 people in it. Whatever the barrier is, I passed that barrier
a long time ago. Again, actual subhuman ADIQ
loser. Uh that could be a problem. That's not anything that helps
here. That was the dumbest thing I've ever heard said in my entire
life. Oh, is there wizard block? Keep running. Keep Are you in?
>> I'm in. Are you saying
zero? >> We'll see if uh we'll see if spider's going to
say anything.
He got the [__] out. I'm wait here for a sec. There
might be somebody running over there.
>> open up. >> I posted something in P's Discord
and deleted it.
Are you talking about this? >> Talking about the current
the current stream or what?
No, no, just talking
>> No, we don't support Joang T.
>> Bro, I don't want to get [__] >> I'm
shooting. >> I don't give a [__] Okay, I'm
in [__] the Jag Discord. I don't give a [__]
Okay, I left. I'm not in there anymore. Okay, go [__]
>> No, I was in there, but I left now. I left out. I left
now. Um, >> do bad,
>> dude. I don't know. Yeah, the the the amp the dancing
back and forth between No, we have to go after these people cuz
they dox and doxing is what you should be allowed to do anyways.
Is doxing even that bad, guys?
>> If you do someone, you should I don't care if you get
doxed. Like that's not
>> Are they listening?
Go hop on. Huh?
Unless you're
>> Well, I wasn't listening this morning.
>> I I'm not going to talk to this destiny loser. I'm not
not with uh I just
I'm never ever gonna give him like a hint of anything going on
with his stuff, right? With any of his legal
and I am totally fine answering like what do you call it like
u asynchronous questions but I'm not going to I'm not going to
be in a call with him to have him spur out and act like a child
the whole time like he did with Doobie. It's gross. No, but also
it's just that so even if I didn't have information that like
I'm not giving him a hint on like I'm never going to actually
just answer a question from him like on the fly.
Even if that weren't the case, even if I wasn't concerned about
that,
I've seen from the Pisco conversation and the Doobie conversation,
there's no way to have a conversation with this guy unless someone's
willing to mute him where he's not just going to spur and try
to like shift the entire time you're talking,
did well in the debate last night. Oh, my wand. My one did well.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I didn't even see that yet. I didn't see get
a chance to see any of that. But no, we'll see. We'll see. We'll
see. He'll just leave. He isn't used to being muted. Uh maybe
I just like there's just no reason to have the conversation.
Like I am totally fine with if he wants to lay out questions
he has for me. I'm fine with taking my time answering them and
then asking a question back,
But that's not what he wants. That's why he's got me blocked
on Twitter. >> Wait, Dirt Zero. Is your name dirty the
>> So, what happened to you during the forth thing? Uh,
no. That's actually not true. Creeper dude. When you listen to
the f to that conversation, I'm saying the things that are correct.
I didn't realize until after that that talk that I said all the
things that correct. I was correct in that conversation. I like
went and watched it after the fact.
But it doesn't matter, right? cuz he's like like literally in
this entire space. If you're in this space, you've been like
programmed to listen to this guy and think like spurking out
at 90 miles a minute saying nothing relevant to any point is
good is like a win. It's like a W.
Uh I got this from I actually got this from Nick Fuentes. I went
to go watch when I was a big DG head. I went to go watch and
debunk one of Nick's streams like trying to on Destiny and I
noticed that when he slowed it down and it's like it's not totally
fair because it's hard to speak fast like on the fly and like
get your ideas out on the fly. But when you slow him down and
just listen when he's doing that like motormouth thing where
he's listing all these things, he's not thinking. He's just in
list mode trying to say anything he can. And when you put it
all together, it's just like a co of it's a it's an argument
co. Okay. bunch of really arguments put together, rattled off
really quickly to make it sound like he's informed or correct.
But if you slow it down and say, "I want to talk about this."
He tries to he tries to run past it, right? CDO collateralized
debt obligation.
Collateralized debate obligation. Okay, that's what he does.
Isn't that a gish gallop? Um, well, it's a it's probably a gish
gallop. Yeah. Yeah, it's probably a gish galp, I would
Um, but yeah, collateralized debate obligation. It's just a bunch
of arguments. I guess it is a Gishkal, but it's the way he does
it like speedily and then he basically keeps trying to move you
forward in the conversation, right? And he'll say, "No, you're
not answering me. No, you're not answering me." But he just said
like four or five
probably three of them. Totally. And he never wants to stop and
let you answer them. Yeah. No, it is like a co Wendy. Yeah, exactly.
Gish Gallop is multiple arguments, not just listing things. Well,
it's sort of like multiple reasons why he believes something,
right? And he'll go LIKE, "OH MY GOD, ARE you kidding me? There's
nothing but there's this and this this this this." And that you
when he's doing it, verbal cover fire is a good one. Yeah, I
like it.
But it's um it's just obvious. And there's very little you can
do about that on the fly, right? All you can do is stand is stand
still and say, "I'm not moving until we discuss the thing you
just said." But then it's just going to turn into a meta argument,
right? And he would much rather have that meta argument than
the actual conversation. Is what you're referring to? I clipped
it when you referenced it yesterday. Oh, did you?
Hold on. Yeah. I I just find it funny that I was like I was watching
some Fentto's piece of content because he covered Destiny. I
was like, "Oh, I should like debunk this on stream and show like
how easy it is to do this." >> he mentioned closing waterways
has been a historical norm for war and now now international
law doesn't matter. >> It's No, no. I'm just saying that
like when I'm looking at like justifications for either side,
what I'm thinking of is like a like a war crime or not is not
like I'm just trying to look at the reality of the situation
on the ground. Like for instance, it might
This is what I'm talking about, but I thought it was a different
thing. This is going to be a different thing. This is Destiny
like speaking fast and then saying things that like he uses so
many words because he doesn't want the other person to talk,
right? So, he's using so many words,
but he's not thinking about the words. >> Dude, what? Let's
Let's play that back in 75 and write it down and let's see how
stupid that sounds when you don't say it with any confidence,
you know, cuz Hey,
>> he's out. He's attacking the tone
He He was calling out the tone indicators in 2022, 2023. What
the is like, "Wait a second. You don't care about what's a war
crime, but you just said that that Israel is justified because
Egypt committed a war crime. What's your response?"
I'm just saying that like when I'm looking at like justifications
for either side, what I'm thinking of is like a like a war crime
or not is like I'm just trying to look at the reality of the
situation on the ground.
So,
no, I'm not looking at definitions. I'm just looking at the situation
on the ground
is all of that,
>> The response to what he's like the fact that he's responding
to a question like that is it makes it significantly worse. You
mentioned >> how easily Desi can confuse people in the
right is impressive.
Is it? Is it?
It's Yeah, maybe.
It certainly works.
It's like, man, I just can't get over how Trumpian it's become.
It's all >> Closing waterways has been a historical norm
for war and now now internet.
>> Yeah. Anyway, that is the clip that's shocking that
you got the precise clip I was thinking of right here where you
slow it down and then you laugh at these people or you laugh
at him specifically. It's way worse with the listing. And Pisco
is trying to do that, right? Pisco is listening to him listing
off reasons that like Pisco is wrong or Pisco is stupid or Pisco
is like bad faith. And Pisco will go, "Whoa, you just said this.
Can we go back and like analyze this?" And he go, "No, no, no.
You're not even listening to what I'm saying. I'm trying to say
like something, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. We can't
go back. I'm going to go No, no, no, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO. You
have to listen to me right now. I'm going to talk right now and
I'm going to go really fast on it. $1, $2, $3 350. So for $350,
like that's the whole game, right? And by the time he's gone
through like four things like that, Pisco doesn't even remember
the character attack that was like 90 seconds ago, but a thousand
words ago. So
that's the issue. That's why I'm just like, "Okay, I will respond
to him, right? just either write down what you want to ask or
I'm totally fine like writing back and forth what it is, but
the problem is if you write it back and forth, you lose the tone
indicators,
You have to present your evidence and make the argument. You
lose the tone indicators, which is like 90% of the battle for
him, and you let the other person respond categorically. If he
had to have text conversations over this, he would get decimated.
Don't you dare ask him to speak slower? Well, the funny thing
is Ozel is he used to allow people to go like, "Hey, slow down.
Slow down. Let's like talk through this, but he didn't do it
Pisco." And if he's not going to do it for a guy who was like
one of his best friends just like a year ago, there's no shot
he's going to do it for me. 0% chance. >> Doesn't matter.
>> It's No. No. I'm just saying that. >> Oh, I don't
want to keep doing this.
>> Are we almost done with Spider? Jesus Christ. Spider,
finish. dirty zero.
Okay, this is the last day we're going to spend more than like
an hour on this stuff. Okay, I don't care if we want to do like
updates in days, but this is like got to be like the last day
we spend more than an hour on this stuff cuz it's like actually
crazy how much time it takes. >> Do you say like do you
have that same like um
what's the word?
So, I mean with like no new developments, it was just people
talking about it randomly or whatever. It's not a big deal. >> What
about food shops like saying like, "Oh, I don't care if like
Dan someone's family gets [__] ducks or sorted."
Like, do you care? >> She said she didn't care. Not that
it >> Uh, she said it was good. She said she hopes it happens.
That's actually different. I I'm almost positive she said she
hopes it happens, right? I'm glad I'm glad that your wife gets
harassed.
Uh, >> I think she was >> Spider just asked
raging out. I don't know if her community does that. So, when
she says it, I don't know how likely it is that someone will
do it. >> Her community does do that. It's literally the
Destiny community. >> I I know that uh the people inside
of J >> Spider's on a quest of discovery. I have faith
he'll get there eventually. Spider on his quest of discovery
is going to discover Atlantis. He's going to find a way that
no sane person could ever find and he's going to find Atlantis.
Okay, that's what he's going to discover. Nobody, nobody with
any, you know, any functioning five senses could possibly find
it, but he'll find the path >> Community when they say
we should do someone or we should harass someone, they actually
do it or it happens right after someone says that. So I think
the cause of link is much higher when those people say something
like that. But if if if that happens after hop say it, I think
uh she should face some consequence for that as well. Yeah.
Oh, I'm not even listen. I don't care about this. I don't care.
I'd rather listen to Pisco do his little thing at the beginning
or whatever. His like little blurb. We'll watch the Pisco blur
and then we'll
>> I don't know how much longer I'm going to stream for
and I will >> I know it's kind of
>> see if people come on. I get that. This is the other
thing is if I do this content, if I do like the Destiny adjacent
content, I'm not going to get I'm not going to be able to get
people to come on, right? That's the other thing. And I like
doing collaborative content. I like having people come on. So
for as long as I talk about Destiny to any like significant degree,
I won't be able to get people on because he's just going to threaten
to dox them. So even if it's like even if it's like just sort
of adjacent in time, I think. So I probably have to chill on
the coverage there or it's going to start to really affect the
stream.
>> Five to 10.
We'll do encounters with uh bigger streamers with with
like breaking points with other people I can collab with for
the goal of like getting my name out there. But I'm not trying
to pander
or cater
or attack particular communities except perhaps with the exception
of MAGA, the the community of people who are running our country
right now. Maybe with that particular exception. Um you might
not believe me. That's my intent. And why would I, right? Why
would I want to needlessly antagonize people?
I don't have any interest in being like disliked.
Who has that desire? I don't want to be disliked.
I generally want to be liked. Um but I also don't want to be
like this fake person who just tries to be nice with everyone.
I kind of take the view that
um if you haven't like made enemies or like made people upset,
you're probably doing something wrong.
Is Perry at risk? Perry's lucky because he's uh banned from the
Discord. >> That doesn't mean you want people to be >> Oh,
I haven't watched the action of Vell video yet either. Damn.
>> Or angry at you or consider you to be like, I don't
know, Persona Nrada.
Uh that I certainly don't want that. But as a consequence of
like ever making any kind of opinion known. Um I guess if all
you did was like cooking streams,
you could write that line. Harry's banned for um streaming from
the Discord in a non-sreamable Discord. It's going to be banned
for a while. Can't let that go down, man. >> But then it's
you probably get someone who like doesn't agree with what you
call a sandwich or you know, you're not supposed to use cream
and uh carbonara or some other debate or some [__]
you know? So, by virtue of being on the internet and having a
society, you're going to upset some people. But it's not my like
desire to do that. I don't want again hate. I don't want to cause
hate.
You know the kind of people I interact with all the time that
we disagree massively. Rob no, good logic. >> He's talking
about that. [__] I have to go back to the beginning.
I might have to go find a time stamp for this. Um
but the Perry stuff it's just a Yeah. Fact of the matter. If
you if you're streaming
and you're going to
Yeah. like pull that up. Wait, he doesn't have like cams up or
something. He like literally Yeah. I don't know. I he might not
ever be coming back to the >> Viva Frey um counter points.
>> And that sucks cuz I like Perry, but like literally
nothing of value is lost for as long as he's going to
be a performative like
refuse to engage like seriously with
and just violate the rules in general. Like it's just like, okay,
you've made yourself like totally radioactive. And it's sad because
I I find you funny, but like if you're gonna make yourself totally
radioactive, don't make me stand there and get cancer. >> Uh
Hutch, it is not my desire. I don't get any gratification
from seeing these people suffer
or wanting my people to go attack their communities or anything.
There are comments that um in like my chats and stuff or in my
discord that are highly critical of other people and streamers.
I my policy has been usually one of maximal free speech. >> By
the way, um just in case people think this, Alex Novel didn't
complain to me or anything. I don't think he messaged me about
it.
Did he talk to me about it? I didn't talk to him about it. I
just found out that Perry made a video and I literally just went
to go look at who was in my VC and what VC they were in. It wasn't
from the streamable VC. I just instantly banned Perry. I didn't
even know what was really going on. I just heard Perry made a
video from the Discord and then I saw what video or what channel
he's making it from immediately like no thank you. >> You
know, I'm I'm going to be real with you. I never argued on these
kind of like Twitch platforming or
um you banning censorship stuff that it was right to ban all
these Trump people or all these antivax or whatever.
Okay. I always just said like it's not a government issue. It's
not Biden's fault. it. >> So, this is nothing to do with
this actually like a this is a really horrible example for what's
going on right now. I don't know why he's talking about ideas.
It's not ideas. It's that you have somebody who is like actively
it's like saying, well, like I think people should have freedom
of speech. So, when this guy says that he shouldn't have to wear
a mask and he should be allowed to cough on whoever he wants,
I just let him into my store cuz I believe in freedom of speech.
Well, it's like, no, they're actually advocating for like doxing
people um based on no criteria, nothing they can prove, right?
Just vibes. That's it. And they just tied you to the vibes. You
shouldn't really have to think about who's in the right or wrong
here. It's very obvious who's in the wrong. I've never threatened
Pisco in any way. I've actually I've never got I've made it very
clear. Do not go after in like a in any way except laughing at
them any of the people I cover on stream. This is all meant to
just be we're laughing. As up as it is, you don't go after them
for anything else, okay? Unless they've done something specifically
to you. Even from Pisco's own interest, Destiny was endorsing
Well, sorry. Yeah. No, it's in Pisco's interest not to have people
who will argue for doxing with no proof, right? That's bad. That's
obviously bad. Um, all of those people were trying to stream
from his Discord, trying to break his rules. What happened when
people brought up the Destiny drama with Zip Zip there? I disconnected
instantly. I went to my Discord. I ated. I said, "Don't talk
about that in their Discord. Pisco doesn't want that in his discord."
I joined one of my own VCs to bring people over to my discord.
Right?
That's what somebody said the word destiny. I was like, "Okay,
I'm out. Bye." Disconnected, went to my discord, joined a different
channel, adhered, got everybody. I said, "Hey, if you want to
join a VC, I'm in a VC now. Do not talk about that in Pisco's
Discord. That's not what he wants." What did Destiny's community
do? What did Destiny and Destiny's community do? Destiny went
to Pisco's Discord to litigate this specifically the thing he
did that Pisco didn't want litigated. I didn't
I talked about Zip Zip's combo with Pisco. That's what I talked
about. And then I went to I went to listen to the Pis the Pisco
Zip Zip combo because I'd heard that Pisco is not being gentle
with him. Okay. Pisco is kind of like tearing this guy limb from
limb. It was very funny.
And then I was playing Civ and then I asked Zip Zip some questions
and then I dipped the out. That's That's how that went. I didn't
go to discuss drama at all. The only time I've discussed drama
in Pisco's Discord is when I feel like I should defend myself
in some way. Like I'm being I'm being accused of something I
didn't do. Other people bring it up. I think I should have the
right to
And I didn't even I even didn't do that occasionally. I would
say I would message him out and be like, "Hey, this person is
bringing this up. Can I respond, please?"
That level Okay. That level of of colored person existence. Okay,
that's what I that's what I am in Pisco's Discord. Okay, I'm
I go to the colors only fountain in Pisco's Discord. Okay,
that's how it is. And I'm okay with that. I'll deal with that
and show people that like I'm not going crazy. I'm not like I'm
not trying to get anybody hurt, obviously.
And that whenever somebody says that I've done something that
I haven't done, I'll just go, "Hey, do can you prove that at
all? Can you literally show me any evidence of what you're saying?"
No, actually mass hysteria never happens. Mass delusion never
happens. Certainly, we're not in a cult. Pisco is, as Pisco is
watching people tell him that they can't believe how bad faith
he was to Hutch when Hutch gas lit him for like an hour and a
half, wouldn't answer a single hypothetical, made a face, like
Pisco is the every single time Pisco asked him a question for
like an hour and a half before Pisco became any amount of heated
at all. And then he gets told, "Hey, why are you like so bad?
Why are you like such an to Hutch? Why are you such an evil person
to
So he sees it. Everybody sees it who's
but man I'm
as one step two steps forward one step back is like how it feels.
Okay. Like I see Pisco seeing it and then I see other people
I'm like dude these people suck.
Anyway anyway >> it's not like coercion but they and they're
private companies. They can do what they want. That was always
extend my argument. >> This might be controversial for
some of
I would let antivaxers on Twitch. Okay.
Maybe I would think hard about it in the context of >> so
in a pandemic
>> antiaxers talking to them about being antiax is something
right
talking to them about it but then letting them congregate around
you in your physical space or if somebody's a doctor letting
them congregate around you in your digital space. That is scary
right and then it comes down to analyzing. I say I don't want
doxing in my community. I don't allow anybody who doxes. I don't
allow post of like screenshots from Kiwi. None of that stuff's
allowed in my community. It's not allowed. Hasn't been allowed
since before Destiny made these allegations, right?
And
people just lie about my position.
It's literally me saying, "I don't support doxing. I don't like
doxing. Doxing is gross.
It's obviously like the exact position everybody else has had
forever." Right? And then they say, "No, you do. You do you you
like that position? I'm like, "No, I don't. Show me any events."
And they're like, "Everyone knows,
brother." What? Sorry, I'm talking
play. I'm play agencies that will change my mind about >> The
idea is is that there's a reason you have certain policies in
place. And when you have doxers, them being there supporting
doxing saying, "Hey, I should dox anybody who does like XYZ."
And after you've been green lit by Destiny, right, which he'll
totally roll back because he he knows he can't actually stand
on that.
But when you've been green lit by Destiny, every anybody in your
Discord is green lit, too.
And then he's constantly saying, "Oh, why won't anybody help
me dox? I need to dox so many more people. Why won't anybody
help me?" Like, that is a that's a risk, right? That is a threat.
Certain types of stuff. But in general, I'm pro free speech.
I don't love all the algorithm changes and all the stupid [__]
that Avon has done on Twitter, but in general, I am happy that
a bunch of people got unbanned. That's my substantive position.
And I carry that value through into how I run a lot of my chats
to the chagrin of even some of my mods.
I see for example Tomato in the chat who is often frustrated
with me because um she like I don't give her good guidelines
as to who to ban and who to like time out and stuff. And the
reason is I have just a very relaxed I've always had a very relaxed
policy and everyone knows that. Um and even bad faith criticism
of myself I let stay on my comments. I there people sometimes
like listen who will be there and will be like wait why are you
like muting comments or like that doesn't happen. Um maybe there's
like a YouTube thing sometimes if you like do certain work >> isn't
doobie banned. Yeah he I think he joked about zip zip coming
on car doors >> but it's never a process of mine. You have
to reach some like very high threshold for me personally to like
want to want to even mute you. >> I haven't muted many
people on Twitter. Sometimes I like I don't see everything where
I'm being pinged on Twitter just because of I I get a lot of
pings and stuff. So I miss stuff, but I'm not the kind of person
who tends to block, who tends to ban. Um, and anyone who's kind
of interacted with me knows that it's like cuz I liked the disagreements
that it's no other reason other than like it's a kind of thing
I like and I like disagreeing with people and for it to be sort
of limited to the disagreement. That's always been how I've operated.
Okay, that said, there always have to be rules, right? No one
under 18 allowed in the server. What are the other rules? against
rules.
No encouraging things that are like toos
um to the for
for some of these places. Um hate speech, even though I don't
like agree with hate speech as like a as like a legal like you
should be banned for saying hate speech or you should be in trouble
for it. Um I do think that that's usually in line with to same
thing with like NS NSFW.
There are some areas where I'm like, okay, it's not that kind
of place. Okay. And even though I think like there's a high standard
for like the criminal world of threats, encouragement, that kind
of stuff, it's different when it comes to like this is all stuff
you probably know, right? It's like a lower threshold. Like even
if this wouldn't meet the criminal standard, if you're kind of
encouraging bad stuff from like a direct way, oh, my bad. That's
going to be banned. So there are some limitations. I'm not trying
to say there's speeding up. >> Um but in general, like
very very
um liberal in the sense of allowing disscent, allowing a difference
of opinion and what have you. By and large, it's focused on politics,
law stuff.
>> Absolute free speech is a gateway to hell. Literally,
nobody's advocating for
>> Okay, that's um some baseline. And like I mentioned
before, I don't have an intent like I don't want to upset people
on purpose. When I have debates, even very vigorous debates,
even [__] with like um Tim Pool, like Tim offline,
we he accused Tim accused me of supporting the shooting of these
National Guard people publicly in front of everybody. And even
after that, right, like I don't want to
I I'm not in the mood like it doesn't make me necessarily happy
to see um bad things happen to him or anything like that, except
if he like broke a law or something or if he like, you know,
some [__]
>> So the long and short of this, by the way, is that Pisco
is banning all discussion of Ethan and Destiny from his >> related
to misconduct, you know, but just on the basis of that, that's
not it, right? Doesn't mean I don't I'm not petty. I don't sometimes
have like ego arguments to defend my positions when I think they're
being unfairly attacked, but in general, that's my stance. Um,
and all types are allowed. Everyone gets a chance
to be in compliance with the rules. Um, especially on the server.
Yes, in the chats and that kind of thing. You get a
Okay. Um, so let's talk a little bit about the more specifics.
I'm aware that there are snarker communities, right? There are
communities who are dedicated to um snarking which is like runs
the gamut from like unfair
slash weird creepy logging of people's activities. Um I'm going
to turn off the sound but thank you very much. Tracking people
what they say criticizing them. Right. So things that are um
>> wait should that really be two and three? Hold on. One
I can kind of get being creepy. Wait, why did he say the second
two? >> Thank you very much. >> Tracking people what
they say, criticizing them, right? So things that
>> cracking what people say and then criticizing them.
>> What that
is weird or offputting or annoying or criticism, right? They
run the game from that to like criminal activity, um things that
are harassment that infringe on people's privacy. And I think
that it should be clear that I never want that. I do not want
to encourage that kind of stuff and I wholeheartedly condemn
the that side of it. I think that there's a difference between
like genuine criticism uh people talking about hypocrisies to
the kind of activities that um put people in fear or that where
it's reasonably questionable whether privacy interests are being
respected um or whether people are sort of encouraging other
things that kind of thing but it's not my intention to promote
um that version of sarking >> and even beyond that um the
kind of single-minded focus on a on particular individuals is
something I don't want to encourage either. I don't want to be
a place whose only identifying feature or um
through line pertains to one or two or three individuals except
for me. I want the through line of my community to be about me.
I don't want it to be about
>> I wish I had the choiceing specific
>> I sure love watching the right-wing covering all that.
I wish I had a >> That includes
>> everyone else is like I'm just staying in my lane. I'm
just staying in my lane. Meanwhile, Destiny's like cutting uh
he's like actually just
sending consistent uh what is it? Jams into my community and
they're like, "Well, I wouldn't want to look over there. That
sure sucks, man. I wish that wasn't happening.
Here, Desty, here's a bunch of money for more JDAMs."
There's some analogy here where the the communities are the US.
Okay. It's like, bro, I just You guys call this guy out? What
the going on? It's like you're under a spell. that includes um
Destiny that includes
>> that includes any number of different creators and stuff.
I don't want my community to be just places where the focus is
only on particular individuals. The kind of thing that happens
after that is it becomes a more like snark congregating situation.
So I don't want my stuff to be that. >> You know I have
issues with people like Adam friended and what he's uh you know
he blocked me and >> I do I do get what he's saying. I
wish I had a choice man. >> I've had issues with um other
streamers etc. You you you don't see in my videos that I I post
out there just like one person going after them all the time,
right?
Except for Trump and MAGA and like politics stuff, right? But
certainly not of the streamer kind because it's not my interest
and it's not what I want to cultivate. That's about intent. Now,
I think
the kind of standard that I impose on my community is one that
ought by and large perhaps with some exceptions. You guys can
talk about that if you want in this chat. Don't [__]
talk about in the discord. That's we'll talk about the rule change
um momentarily, but just know that everything's in here. The
rule is clear in the discord. All right,
that the standards that I apply for my community are self-standing
and self-contained. You know, think about the issue with the
Venezuelan interceptions, right, of the Americans going to intercept
in international waters. I don't think that my rules apply outside
of where I hold a dominion, which is my different places. Okay,
there's a kind of limitation both that I think I can do, right?
But also one in which I think is like reasonable to expect in
that the server isn't a kind of social club where we're checking
applications at the door to make sure that you're you're have
a good character. It's not like in a some kind of co-op where
we're getting statements of good character, you know, your invoices
and stuff. It's a generally open space of people to participate
and the rules of
bro. Okay, don't give me friends. J's community is pretty intense
in terms of their intentions, but I don't see doxing or harassment
or celebration of doing so in there.
okay, dude. Um,
I was just, dude, Pisco people be like, Pisco is so bad. Faith
with Hutch. It's crazy. He's so wordy all the time. You ever
listen to this guy yap by himself?
This guy can't make a point to save his life by himself. Okay.
And you're going to say he's bad faith to Hutch. No, he's bad
faith to humanity. He's always this wordy. Okay. He's by himself
just yapping to his chat. And he's still this wordy of the space.
Don't go elsewhere. Except to which there's like a hook to conduct
on >> I shouldn't yell if you're someplace else and and
the conduct affects the server in that you're um invoking it
or you're directing stuff to it. That that's areas in which um
obviously there's like a hook to the the server conduct. Um,
I also think it's a bit much to expect that other rules, rule
sets from other places predominate my space, right? Because everyone
has their own rules.
Everyone has their own standards for what is acceptable and what
is not
>> I get how this is like good when you're
It's probably because I think I listened to this this morning.
I I just couldn't sleep today. Okay. So, I was like listening
on and off to stuff like as I was falling in and out of sleep
and I think I listened to most of this. So, I already get the
point. He's basically gonna say like,
I can't control other people's [__] but this is how
it's going to be here. I want my community to be about me, about
my ideas. And he was like, I don't want to make money. Like,
I could just do snarking if I want to make money. No, that's
not like how you make money. You make money by carving out a
lane for yourself. You got to carve out a lane, bro. And I think
he the best lane he can carve out is like the legal one who gives
his legal opinion on things. But I do think there could be a
pretty big lane for the guy who like goes in on Ethan Klein and
shows just like is willing to argue those things, which you probably
can't argue that with DJers, right? And I think he he was going
around arguing his friends, arguing with his friends. If he could
have pulled like a Dioro debate, if he could have pulled like
a Ethan Klein direct debate, if he could have pulled a debate
with one of these people, that would be different. >> You
know, want to create a snark community of a certain kind. Maybe
it's the kind which is
really bad. Maybe it's the kind which is just like kind of mere
criticism. Maybe it's like you don't remember fundy snark which
is like the fundamentalist snark. Maybe it's like a topic related
snark. Maybe it's banan pit poles whatever that's their responsibility
that's them. They do they go do that and their participation
in that I think um you know is their interest
but it's not something that I until and unless it is directly
implicated how I want to run the server
relating to me. In other words, everyone gets a shot in the place
to follow my rules in my place.
And if someone tries to tell me, hey, you should run your server
differently. These are the kinds of things that you should do.
I'm interested in hearing that. Tell me why.
Uh, not through Discord. Okay? I mean, like conceptually, I mean,
so don't go tell me send all seven stuff in Discord. Okay? So
again, reiterating the rule in Discord is as it is. It hasn't
changed. But what I mean to say is like I'm open to hearing.
>> Imagine if he could have got in a legal mindset conversation
on that. That's where I think he'd have to go, right? is to he'd
have to start breaking into I don't know why he doesn't just
go argue with these law people all the time on everything. Go
figure out what legal mindset's doing videos on criticize. Go
figure out dude
L tube Stark would go pretty insane. Okay, I think L tube Stark
could be I mean L tube basically is Stark already, but it could
go crazy. I'm telling you
>> on other circumstances like what are better ways in
which one should ought to run their server or their different
place or their chat, whatever, right? I'm open to that. 100%.
>> He has done that. I
I know kind of >> what I don't accept. >> Wait, and
Bailey isn't like the uh Hold on. Who's and Bailey? I don't know
who >> I'm not just >> I just I'm going to click
on it cuz I just want to see real quick.
Wr of the Bailey YouTube. Wr of the Bailey. No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, that guy. Oh, that guy. I recognize that guy's face. I recognize
that dude. That dude's got a really memorable face. I'm not defending
J, whatever. Oh, by the way, um, one thing clear, >> hold
on, hold on, hold on. Let me go >> I I truly, you know,
I probably the best amongst us if I if I have to say anything.
And, uh, all the hate he receives online entirely,
bro. The [__] is this?
Just the the Ultra Orthodox Jew by Israel's draft. What your
ball size says about you.
Final Fantasy 10 by Gracini Project. Venu me. Venu meles. It's
my life. whatever I want to do.
>> What an eclectic set of tastes we got over here, guys.
>> Uh, but I'm I'm not willing to defend him against the
charges of being the new Duke Docker. >> Yeah, dude. Can
you have a like a personality trait? Sorry.
>> All right. I'm not I'm not defending J. Whatever. Oh,
by the way, um, one thing clear, I have not made any assertion
as to the rightness or wrongness of any particular um I was looking
at VOD and I saw something coming up from from where he's like,
I didn't do certain things. I'm not making any characterizations
of anyone's conduct as relates to what I don't want to talk about.
So, I hope that that is clear that when I'm speaking hypothetically
and conditionally that um those aren't assertions of fact.
>> It was it was absolutely not clear. So much so that
like people were really mad at me for not calling you out. And
so I did actually say like I'm pretty sure this is what he means,
but if he didn't, I think I would like a like an acknowledgement
of that.
People were really mad at me for not calling him out for just
like sort of taking as given some of those things.
>> we love you here at the bunker. I think people everyone
that calls you a tail pipe is just out of line. Um and and we'll
ban them from the bunker. So, we love you, but we're not going
to talk about boring legal topics tonight. We're only talking
about the most interesting legal topics.
they'll ban somebody who calls Wait, is that Zip Zip? Was Zip
Zip on this? They They banned somebody who calls Zip Zip a tailpipe
from their Discord. That's just funny, bro. That's just funny,
dog. Oh,
man. I do wonder I do wonder if there could be like a little
clip is does somebody have a clip of like the morale?
We do have a clip.
Oh, I gotta watch I gotta That's an offshoot server. Yeah, I
gotta watch He's watching his the podcast of his like offshoot
guys. Um
I gotta watch
the clip of Mau talking to Zip Zip to see it. I'm not going to
play it because I just said I wouldn't obviously a little while
ago, but um like
I just I
I'm just positive I know exactly how Morau delivered it. >> And
starting off with you think is the worst lawyer streamer? There's
>> Nope. What a great intro. See, >> what part of
I said I'm not going to play it, so I'm not going to play it.
What What part of that was confusing? >> This is This is
a guy with a planet. Now, Gond, as I understand, he he like floats
in and out of different lawyer communities. I think he's an OG
Bosiot guy. I think that that's right.
>> They're both OG Bosiot guys. I'm pretty sure they're
both like massive Bosia
>> and will not accept >> from being convinced that
I ought to run my server a different way is suggesting
>> um I have to run my server
the way that other people say I ought to run it. That is where
I'm like why
and for the longest time.
Why'd you ban me out from it to make a point that I was going
to first and ask questions later that like I'm pretty confident
he's like um joking there but I would have to hear it exactly
and so I just banned I just banned first and then I'll go and
look at it and we'll figure it out. I just wanted Zip Zip to
admit that he felt threatened
and then hopefully since I since I knew that there was somebody
who did record it and it got leaked I was like well I can go
grab it as well. I have an awareness that people
have different views on this
like um war between communities specific.
Pisco's new rule only benefits Destiny and um he was manipulated
into it directly by Destiny, but it's like it doesn't make it
wrong for his part, right? Like it that can be true,
but it can still be the most beneficial path he could take. And
I pro I would probably agree that that's what it is, right? It's
just the most beneficial path for him to take. And but he was
like like literally I already explained Queen and I dipped before
anybody brought the Destiny stuff, right? I heard the word Destiny.
I I peeled the out of that VC. I was like, "Nope, I'm not doing
that in Pisco's Discord, right? What did Destiny do? Destiny's
community tried rereaming the Discord multiple times to make
it about that." And then Destiny joined and made it about that,
right? He wanted to litigate his drama with people. I explicitly
try to go to my Discord and say, "Hey, if you guys want to talk
about drama, come talk about it here."
Right? So, I think like all of this stuff is just Destiny trying
to force Pisco to stop talking about it. And he was effective
and he he like got it to happen. Um, but I also think that like
for what Pisco wants to do, it's true that he doesn't want to
be involved in that. He probably just doesn't want to be around
any of that,
right?
It's it's just that's the case, man. So I if it wasn't if it
was like like way worse for him somehow if he was really struggling
if his numbers were really bad and he like probably needed to
get like an injection of content some way like maybe I could
criticize it but realistically the guy gets like a good amount
of content even for like some stuff that I find super boring
right like when he's just reading documents. I don't think he
has to do that and I think he's building his niche out and I
think when you're on YouTube and you have like access to the
algorithm you just build your niche man.
I don't know. Destiny did put his foot in his mouth a few fair
few times from what I heard.
Okay. Well, we'll see. See if it makes a difference. >> On
the Destiny side of things and on the anti-destiny side of things.
And my position is listen, I don't want to cultivate either.
I don't want to be in a situation in which I'm encouraging
like pro- snark positions or antisark position such that I am
getting dragged into this mess of stuff I don't want to talk
about and that don't interest me. And doesn't that make all the
sense in the world that I wouldn't want that? Who would who would
want that? Why would I want that? So, there appears to be >> so
rare Emory W. This is probably true, but I'm never going to go
and like push Bisco on it cuz I don't think it'll happen. Like
I I think probably anybody who advocates for doxing as a sincere
position should be banned and like actively engages in it and
actively engages in it against like people who are your friends,
people who are your like colleagues, people around you. I don't
think you can entertain that. I think that's probably going to
be bad for your space overall.
But
hey,
or he just like my community and then none of you guys cross
him and you all pretend like he's really cool and awesome and
then I think that works out for everybody except for me, right?
Like eventually if he just like totally my community by doxing
anybody who's active enough and and doesn't like him and then
you guys like all pretend it didn't happen. I think that could
work out well for everyone else. Probably >> um a suggestion
I should preemptively ban. >> That's like a That's like
a joke but not a joke. You know this one of those jokes that's
a joke but it's not really a joke but it's like kind of a joke
cuz I don't think it'll happen but also ah you never >> certain
people from either sides of that >> I think I think realistically
we've hit like bedrock on the people who will be threatened away.
You know what I'm saying? Like I think we just straight up hit
bedrock on the people who will be threatened away
and it's probably not going to work out.
Yeah, if that was like it's like there are people who will leave
because of it, but it's like realistically the people Destiny
actually scared away were like the sane people who would defend
like all of the lawyers who used to come in and defend his side
of the case in the discord all left.
And there were a bunch there were a bunch of people who come
in and defend his side of the case from like the same perspective
just being like, "Well, I think the law is like this and I I
think this is like how this is." And
they changed my mind on a bunch of things. They like help me
understand a whole bunch of things. But now those people are
all gone.
But maybe that's what he wants. Maybe he wants to like try to
fment the community into something more intense than what it
is. I don't know. From the
>> Oh, that's
unfortunately for him. if he wants to make it like more intense
and get them to do some crazy, that's never going to work, right?
Like I'm always going to be against that. And I've already been
tested on that so many times, right? I've been tested on that
so many times. >> Yo, you shouldn't be talking to counterpoints.
You shouldn't be allowing Zip Zip in your server. These are just
people who are >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Is he acting like
he gets this comment from people?
I will say Zip Zip does a lot of defending doxing with zero thought
behind it. makes it pretty weird. But >> from either side
of that divide, from the pro Destiny side, you know, you shouldn't
be talking to counterpoints. You shouldn't be allowing Zip Zip
in your server. These are just people who are um actively trying
to defend some
>> horrible stuff that's happening and that stuff. So,
understand,
>> but like does he get that criticism from like a lot
of people? Cuz I don't think I've ever said that to him. I don't
even know if I like tell him not to talk to >> that there
is criticism that I have and interact with people who >> Oh
no. Oh no. Don't Don't make no mistake. This is also true. Just
some internet chick. But
he's basically like setting himself on fire to punch me and make
like burn me.
It's [__] up. But I'm getting burned. Okay. Jesus
Christ. It sucks. All right.
He's got the upper ar he's got the upper body strength of a 10-year-old
child. So, he sets himself on fire when he throws punches and
it's up, man. My clothes are all burned up. >> Port like
respect Destiny.
There's plenty of criticism on that level. There's also criticism
of that like people who do not like Destiny
are in the server
and are in my chat. I
I really feel like this is one of those things where I'm like,
"Pisco, be serious." Right? Like, actually, be serious for two
seconds. Are you getting these in equal amounts? Pisco, Pisco,
Pisco, are you getting these in even amounts? Are these like
equal? Can we You be serious? Can you be real? Can you not be
fake right now? It's He's King Solomon. He's King Solomon right
now. Okay. He's splitting the baby in half. either because of
personal disagreement with those people because those people
>> in Snork in other places, you know, uh just Jilk should
not be in the server.
Oh, by the way, before he gets into this, the people who would
like most snark on Destiny are people who were doxed by Destiny
or had their nudes released by Destiny, just to be clear. So,
like the people who would like post like that swimsuit picture
of him or whatever on the beach where you like you should see
the the body and those people those are the people who' like
they post that and I'm like you know what
I'm not going to I'm not going to mod that. I understand I could
mod it. I understand. I could like try to say no, don't make
fun of his appearance,
but like realistically, I'm sorry, with Destiny being the person
who had either doxed them first or had like released nudes of
them, released um sorry, videos of them without their consent.
Like there's a bunch of people like that,
I just I feel like the people who did it most Yeah. are those
people. He should be out of it. Um you know, not Zip Zip, but
just Tilk.
not counterpoints and Destiny who I I believe was in the server,
but
um Quimman, not Kafka, but any other number of people. Couldn't
Pixie and Cherry be totally banned in these spaces? In his spaces?
Uh I think they are. Pixie is mega snarking.
Well, I mean, he started calling for ICE to arrest Pixie's wife
or something. So me trying to
those groups
in virtue of their offserver conduct
necessarily involves me applying
um a rule set beyond the scope of my own
and necessarily involves me waiting in in a dispositive way.
Snip and chase dock are not analogous at all. No, that's true.
Um, that's totally true. When I was in the Destiny community,
I was the person sitting there being like, "Dan, you can't do
that here. You ever do some [__] like that again,
you're gone permanently. No questions asked." Okay, Destiny,
I get that you're like the reason I'm making the money I'm making
right now. You ever do that [__] again on my server,
you're out of here. No exceptions. Like, I'll I'll bite that
bullet. Don't make me do it. Right? Like I was the person who
as much as I got run rough shot over, okay, as somebody who'd
only been streaming for like a year and I wasn't like prepared
for that. I'm nothing like these people. I You know what the
problem is? Uh the problem is that I made really easy money before
this and this is also like I'll be honest kind of easy money.
Um and so I don't know. I'm like I I'll criticize this but I'm
criticizing myself.
I
I'm too willing to like sacrifice to stand on principle. I like
didn't learn enough from the real world. Most people who have
been run over by life will absolutely just take the money and
not question it. Okay. You're like somebody who's had like a
rough time who's come from like poverty. They'll like they'll
they just they're like, "You know what? I should just take the
money." Like
You know what I'm saying? Uh but I I stand against that. I guess
I don't know what Zip Zip's excuse is. He's young. He should
be stupid. He should be stupid and idealistic. And he's
he's like principally he's like principally
It's very bizarre. It's like the only thing I can think is like
the the cultlike elements on that front way.
And he's humble too, ladies. I mean, I'm not like I'm not saying
I didn't, but I was honest as well. People in spicy chat used
to give me like why are you why are you sweeping for this guy?
And I'm like, honestly, like I feel like he's not a great person,
but probably mostly financial incentive. Like I'm making insane
money right now.
Probably like I I I can't separate it. I'm a well I'm well aware
I can't separate it that like I probably should. This was after
the leaks but before the January leaks like I as far as I know
my opinions were fairly in line with like Queenman or Chud going
into like the first week of the new year in 2025.
I was like, "Well, I think probably it was done without consent,
but realistically, I feel like you got to wait on somebody making
a definitive statement who's willing to pursue something, so
I'm kind of chilling." And I didn't know about any of the Pixie
DMs or the straight raid leaks or whatever in the background.
So, I was just sitting there like, I'm saying this and I I can
tell people are getting angrier and angrier about it. People
are getting mad mad mad that I'm letting it get talked about.
And oh, I wonder where that would have gone if things hadn't
like blown up when they
I got perma banned in here for bringing up the leaks when they
happened. Yeah, but shut it down. You understand that? That was
for Pixie sake and not for Destiny, right? That I banned I literally
I don't know if it was like the next day, but I banned
mentions of any of the victims and then I said you could talk
about the leaks broadly, but like mentioning like any of the
non-consentual victims, those people was wrong. Don't do that.
Right. Like I I was like naming people. You could talk about
it in an abstract, but naming people is awful.
You kick Kelly off the stream one time and she almost out of
pixie. I did do that. And then she somehow thought she was really
intelligent. Was like, "Oh, but
I I was I can't even remember what she she's so stupid. Thank
god we're through that era. Holy shit." Um
yeah, I do. Don't even remind me. I don't want to talk about
it, man. Grontos blew it up a little. Yeah, I promand him for
that. I literally It wasn't like I'm like, do you think I'm trying
to protect Destiny by not screaming Pixie's name when she's trying
to deny that she's in the leaks? Do you think I'm honestly trying
to protect Destiny by doing that? Like, did anyone could anyone
be
for real?
And un like I I just got lucky that uh I talked to Queen a lot
at that time and I could just be like unfortunately like right
off of his I'm like dude I've got the same ability as he does.
If you've got criticism like the most unhinged guy you know won't
go and just name Pixie on stream. Why do you think that is? It's
kind of cuz it's like just objectively morally wrong to do. It's
like objectively to do. You let him dock Sunday on your stream
yet he wasn't perma banned. I had some level of reasoning there
for basically I didn't want to call attention to it and I felt
like what Sunday was doing was drawing attention to some things
and that he ran on those leaks as soon as he could. I felt like
Sunday had done some [__]
and then he muted Sunday. Um why I didn't want the leaks run
with on my stream. I didn't want that happen. Right. It was really,
we were having like a good time and then he started like just
doing the Lawrence Southern leaks and this was again this is
like stupid but in my mind here's what I'm thinking right at
that time was this guy's like the victim here. He just had all
these videos leaked or sorry I don't think I don't think I was
like I hadn't had a chance to go through the videos or something
yet because of when I woke up and
like I was streaming. So while I think the videos technically
had leaked maybe like an hour a couple hours earlier that day.
I think we didn't even like Sunday didn't even reference them.
We just didn't know everything that was there. I think the only
thing we really had a good handle on was the right and we were
like having a good time and then Sunday just came and killed
the vibes. And
I feel like the I was actually mostly I think kind of annoyed
that Sunday didn't message me, right?
Sunday came in to totally with the stream. He came in to totally
[__] with the stream and he didn't just shoot me
a message and be like, "Hey, I want to press Desty on this."
which I felt like was super disrespectful to me. Uh, join the
socialist revolution on Twitch. No, thank you, dude. Right-wing
right-wing is so much more interesting. Right-wing populism is
so much cooler than uh leftwing populism. Leftwing like communism.
You guys got like the worst vibes.
Right-wing right-wing
dude.
thank god I came and joined these communities and made like a
bunch of friends here cuz the vibes in like right-wing populism,
right-wing like nationalism, even white nationalism are so immaculate
right now. Like the
the vapor wave hyperoreian
like esoteric
memes. Oh my god. It's like, dude, the vibes are so good, but
I just don't believe in any of it. It's like it's so funny. It's
so funny to me in my head and then I'm like but I don't actually
I'm not actually racist enough. I I wish Dude, if I was racist
enough I could I just make a right now. It's so cool. Be Canadian
Asminol but stronger. Dude, it's like it's funny stuff. I don't
know how to explain it. I It's just so cool, man. It's so cool.
What did you think of Pierre Polyv? I thought he it was overblown
how like evil he was. I thought he's like basically like a neocon
mas. He was like Ronda Santis, like a neocon. Okay, not Ronda
Santis. There's somebody better. Ronda Santis was like one of
the larers who like would lar to the point that like he knows
he doesn't belong and he would lar to the point that he go too
far overboard. That's like Ronda Santis. He was like a larer
who was willing to dog whistle and like wink wink. He's like
um Ri Priebus or like some of those first first administration
Trump guys who's like he's like a total neocon at heart and he's
willing to like go like huh yeah trans people and he like feels
really like he's transgressive and crazy and then but he's like
just dude I need you to sign this $100 million for Israel $100
million for Israel $100 million for Israel right that's that's
how I saw pure polyv was like a total Marco Rubio I I think even
Rubio's a little more populist than Polyv would be. I think Polyv
was like it was all show. He is like a conservative policy wonk.
He's like um Oh, he's like Scott Bessant or something, right?
He's like a conservative policy wonk. He's not he's he's like
a wonk. He is not. And by the way, Bessant didn't approve of
the global tariffs like anywhere near the speed they're going
and Right. Bessent is smarter than that. He was a youth minister
under Harper. Yeah, he's like a total just conservative
neocon, small government, anything guy. Wish we had more Canadian
politics streamers. It's there's no views in it is the unfortunate
thing. There could be views in it, but I'd have to work so hard.
So, we'll have to wait until the next cycle. I'd have to work
hard to find out how to make it funny and interesting, but then
that's like all work you're doing on yourself. Whereas in American
politics, you can tap into a like a schizosphere of memes and
and
everything. Memes, themes, stories. ideas. It's just all there
and it's like there's so much material to work with and Canadian
politics. It's like there's none of that, right?
There's just nothing close.
Also, I would have had a very hard time discussing Canadian politics
and not
like the overton window in Canada on immigration came to where
I was, but I was way out there on I was like, "Dude, that you're
like actually causing a race war. You're like explicitly trying
to cause a race war. You're like like this is every person who
thought the great replacement is real. If they paid two attention
two seconds of attention to Canadian politics, they go, "Yeah,
there's this this is like the most zogged out government who's
trying to like it's like all of the elite. They're trying to
destroy this country first. It's like I swear to God, thank god
conspiratorial populace never discovered Canadian politics cuz
they would have been like this is a testing ground for all of
their like experimental
DEI great replacement garbage." And I'm, by the way, I have got
no problem with Indian Canadians, shockingly, okay? Most Indian
Canadians I've met who aren't like fresh off the boat, brand
new here, are awesome people. Like genuinely awesome people.
Um, and I'm not talking about like one good one. I'm talking
about like dozens of awesome ones who I've met like them and
their families and they're cool and they're awesome, right? But
when you bring in that large auh portion of your population every
quarter,
it's insane.
Like that, there's no way you don't have insane social strife.
And I was just like, dude, they're like actually trying to pop
off some kind of crazy race war in Canada. Ontario, ground zero
for the race war or some I think it's kind of slowing down now,
though. Right. Right. Am I crazy? Can anyone confirm who's out
in Ontario?
Most of it is students. IMO. Well, yeah. It just it was wild
with like jobs and housing and it's like putting all of the wrong
pressures on. It's like you're you're either trying to start
a race war or you're trying to force like some crazy
actual like far-right revolution in your country. took like the
most popular the most polite country in the world, the most not
the least racist country in the world, objectively least racist
country in the world and like tried to experiment with how fast
you could turn them into the like Weimar Republic overnight.
Crazy man. Doug Ford was content to freeze tuition or content,
sorry, to freeze tuition and let the colleges import tons of
foreign students for BS certificate programs for money. Oh, that
is the other problem is that our universities, we might have
the opposite problem of the US where our universities don't charge
enough and so people get like super cheap educations but it's
all subsidized by international students who pay like 10x what
regular students pay. So like while you do get a cheap education,
it's like pretty cool, you do need like a steady supply of students
to keep the system afloat, which is not great. I don't understand
why it would be that hard or how it's that hard to just open
more medical schools in Canada and basically tie like your
I don't know
>> how do we not have I I feel like that would be an interesting
question for Canada specifically like what prevents Canada from
opening up like 50 new medical schools
like just being like we have to actually max out our med schools
get as many doctors trained as possible and flood this like I
understand slowing it down slightly or or like lowering standards
slightly might have some negative consequences, but bro, we need
more
Maybe you don't have the teachers for it. Maybe. Yeah, that could
be a bottleneck. Teachers for it. But like realistically, man.
I don't know. We're subsidized by foreign students as well. It's
just really expensive anyway. Yeah, but you guys are all subsidizing
like your college NFL that exists.
[__] wild. The quality dilution of quality. The quality
is already worse than you think it is. Well, I've described how
my doctor is, right? I've described my doctor. Oh, I think I
don't have her anymore.
I got a doctor who was like straight from Pakistan.
Couldn't speak English. Actually could not speak English at all.
Like I would literally
It was It was wild when I first went in. I'm like, "Here's my
prescription." She's like, "Oh yes, this is good." And I'm like,
"I want more of that." And she's like, "Yes, I'd give more here.
This good? Yeah. Uh, maybe a little more." Yeah. Okay. Okay.
That's a good dose. Thank you. It's like, okay, this is a little
weird. I'm flying by the seat of my pants here.
[__] that,
dude. I'm overstating it, but I'm overstating it by like 10%.
You think I'm like overstating it by a thousand%. I'm overstating
it by like 10%. Like literally, I'm like, "No, no, no. You need
to give me this." And she's like, "I need to rule is we do blood
work first." And I'm like, "No, just" and she's like, "No, blood
work. Blood blood work. Okay, whatever. Go get the blood work
done." And she's like, "Okay, what do you need? What do you need?"
Uh,
long time it was South Asian Medical. Um, I went back to like
my childhood doctor. It's like hours away, but he does do like
tea health. So, and he's South African. Very smart guy. So, very
cool. Very cool. I'm I think I'm back with him now. So, well,
I am back with him. I don't know why I say I think I am back
with him. This isn't what's happening. This isn't what's happening.
This is This is too much.
This is too much. That's not it. That's not a thing. Sorry, we
went off way. We went way off track with some talk about Canadian
politics. Whoa. Boy, we should finish this Pisco content and
then I should uh dip the out. Don't have doctors to teach them.
You'll crash incomes. Okay. But like that's that's a um that's
like a curve problem, right? Like how fast we ramp. That's like
a curve problem. Like you just you literally just do a little
bit. We need to add two more medical schools. Okay, let's see
how that goes. We need to add two more medical school medical
schools now. Okay, let's see how that goes >> on the issues.
>> You said 15x. I know I said I said
I said like 20 new or 15 new medical schools, but it's like you
understand it being hyperbolic. Like that's a
I maybe I speak
in a way that's hard to
figure out or something, right? But like I do just mean we need
to add more. And I would risk adding a little bit too much, but
we should just adding more. Just get to adding more and break
some things to make make it so you can add more and then figure
out if you need to add more. Go just go just go do something.
Do anything >> that I do not want.
Doesn't seem like dollar is going to be worth very much. How
about you just borrow? Okay, everybody's kind of trying to be
like responsible, fiscally responsible. Hey, tomorrow doesn't
exist. Let's just borrow. Let's just go Japanese with it. Okay.
Hey, Canada. Hey, Canadians everywhere. Let's
Let's go for austerity.
Austerity in like every way except infrastructure and education
spending. Okay, we're maxing out science for the next like 20
years and living a very lean lifestyle. Okay, and then we'll
see what happens. And we'll borrow we'll borrow like we're in
East Asia. Let's do it. Let's go
to Wade into which are not interesting for me to wait into which
don't
unless forced. >> It's not it's not debt maxing necessarily.
It's just like, dude, be ahead of the curve. Like, cuz just borrow,
man. I understand interest rates are a little high. Trump's about
to totally boil the economy.
Get ahead of the curve. Let's go. >> Certain accusations
bear on the conduct that happens in the server. So, what is being
requested of me is not to apply my own rules about how I want
to run the stuff. >> Is this like a thing, dude? Where's
uh where's Marty Epstein? Marty Epstein around? He's probably
gone home for Christmas. haven't seen Marty Epstein around the
last little while. Is that a thing where like even though interest
rates are up with how fast inflation's rising, how fast like
the dollar is devaluing, is that a thing that borrowing would
still be as valuable? Feels like no, because of like like rates
are a different metric. But no, but like as inflation kind of
like goes higher and the dollar devalues more significantly,
then that would cut into the interest rate, wouldn't it? Think
he was around tonight? I didn't see him
There's like a concept there that I can't grasp on to because
I am sleepd
Marty here tonight. Marty was not here tonight. Marty hasn't
been here in a while. Marty hasn't been talking in a while,
but Marty was here just like two or three nights ago donating
insane amounts of money. So, >> in my servers talking for
a little bit, >> but some other rules,
some other sets of things. And it's not clear to me
other than
the preferences of other people why that should happen. Why should
I
>> I think I also think that you can have these reasons,
but doesn't this like look worse that you haven't looked into
why do [__] I hate I hate criticizing this guy cuz
it feels like a little dising like it feels rough when he's got
so many people who are willing to come in and just tell him how
he should do everything. Okay.
But man, he uh
it feels like you could say all of this like, "Oh, we want to
give everybody a chance. we want to like do things fairly and
then it's like but you still say you haven't looked into why
doobie is banned >> to the extent that it affects the server
the community that I want to build
>> why is it correct
why is it good that rather than give everyone a chance in my
server
I don't do that people say what about gropers okay
>> well, if a Groper wants to come into the server and
they break the server rules, >> dude, you say this, but
like you say this, but how many rules did Doobie
How many rules has Destiny's community
Like, I'm sorry. They're like, it's [__] up. Listen,
I I get it.
Everybody's equal. We get votes. We're equal. We just have to
go to our own water fountain. Okay, there's the there's the coloreds
water fountain over there for the snarker types and the whites
only water fountain over here for the DG sphere people. Okay,
you go over to your colors only fountain. You drink from there.
I get it.
>> Oh, you drank from the whites only fountain. That's
a ban. That's a ban. >> That's ban. You're done. >> Violated
the rules. >> You're out. I I By the way, I say that mostly
I guess in [__] These mods are nice to me. It's just
the it's the vibe I get sometimes. >> That's called debate.
>> Yeah, we have MAGA people in the server that I talk
to all the time. If there is some intentional,
you know, indication I'm intentionally fostering it, by which
I mean actively trying to create a community of a specific thing.
>> Dude, I'm just going to say it one more time because
I have to. Okay, I have to. The situation last night, we're listening
to Pisco talk to D to what's his name? Zip Zip. The only conversations
we're having is around what Zip Zip was just like blatantly lying
about his conversation with Pisco trying to trying to gaslight
us and pretend that he wasn't totally wrong in everything he
was saying. Okay. Uh but we talked about that and the second
somebody tried to switch over to Destiny drama, we dipped. I
dipped Queen and I think it dipped before, but I dipped. I was
like, "Dude, I don't want I don't want to talk about that Pisco
server." He said he doesn't want to hear.
Contrast our actions with the actions of the Destiny community
trying repeatedly to record that VC Destiny coming in and talking
non-stop about his [__] Like like dude, it's not
close. And if I was doing that,
well, I wouldn't do that. Sharp might be Sharp would probably
give me some kind of benefit of the doubt,
but god damn. And I do know there are some people from my community
who are in the FC listening, but I told them not to. Okay, I
told them not to. I think my wand was in there, but I don't control
that person, dude. Come on, man. I don't control them. They're
on their own.
I missed the memo. Yeah, I got it. Uh, anyway, so I But I didn't
I didn't support that. I tried to explicitly pull people away
from that so that we weren't doing that there.
At least most of the all the snarker types weren't there. Okay,
the snarker types were having a conversation about the new Marvel
trailers that got leaked.
>> All right, that's where that's what we were doing. Very
cool. >> All right, that I totally understand. >> That's
just to me it's like the double standard of the rules, right?
>> And the criticism from that, >> that is not my
intent to cultivate a server of MAGA people or a server of snarkers
or a server of
racist members of the KKK.
>> Dude, none of the gripers who come and sit in the kick
chat ever join the Discord. It's kind of [__] up.
They they're they're Discord avoidant. >> Very unfortunate.
That's not my goal at >> He just looked at his chat. He
just looked at his chat >> and in no sense.
>> He just looked at his chat and a bunch of people are
saying, "Why is Doobie banned?"
And he didn't acknowledge it. Are we going to pretend we can't
see this guy looking at his chat? I know he read his chat. I
know for a fact he read his chat. Some people say that this guy
reads his chat all the time. >> Is this for money? >> Oh,
this is this is cope.
>> Cope in the way you think. first of all, who is banned
from my server for a reason I don't even know. I give a lot of
autonomy to my mods to to be empowered to enforce the rules.
So, I don't even know the basis of Dubbie's ban. I think I asked
maybe once or twice and didn't follow up because I just didn't
have an interest. You can ask Dubbie like whether or not he's
Doobie is banned. But the point is,
Dubbie can spend as much money as he wants
donating in my
uh super chats
and it will not fundamentally change anything about who I am
or how I want to run my server. At most, it'll be like, "Okay,
guys, uh, you know,
fundamentally, no." at the margins, it could definitely change
things.
like I don't I don't know Pisco's financial situation. Okay.
But I assume he's got like a war chest of some kind that he could
operate off of.
Um
piece of evidence. He seems to have started doing this as a job.
He was pretty lax about it at points when he started. I think
if he was like really hurt up for money, he would be streaming
a lot more. Would have been streaming a lot more back then. He
seemed pretty consistent now, but I think he would have been
streaming a lot more back then. Okay. So, I do think that
probably got a bit of a war chest built up. Not concerned about
money. If he was heard up, if he's hurting for money, >> I
do think it could affect >> donated $3. Hello, >> Doobie.
Please donate to me instead.
>> Don't donate to anyone else. Oh, except me. Me.
Thank you for the donation, Dung Devil. Appreciate it, buddy.
Okay.
Oh, what was I saying here? Oh, it could affect you. So, that's
a little bit of coke there. Maybe not. It won't like change his
opinion drastically, but it's a little at the margins would affect
>> Is he what what's happened with his ban? He's like donated
a lot of money. Like, should he be banned?
>> Yeah, this is basically what I'm saying straight right.
But I think he's saying fundamentally like it wouldn't change
his fundamental views. And I do think that's true. Like you're
not going to you're not going to donate Pisco into being a communist.
I just don't think it's going to happen. >> And I didn't
even follow up, right? It's the proof in the pudding. I think
probably just as a matter of fairness you should follow up. But
hey, he donated all this money and I didn't even I wasn't even
fair to him. That's not that's not like cool. That's not You're
kind of just describing being an even money can't make me not
be an [__] and if he wants to donate to me. My question
is >> I that's yeah I do think this is true that in terms
of having your principles be tested. I think Pisco's stood tall
in a situation I've watched a lot of people falter in at least
to like an extent that nobody else really does or has.
Like I see a lot of people falter in that precise situation totally.
He's been tested and it's like
and to no benefit. no immediate benefit
It manifests in the way that you're less likely to say certain
things. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is more what it is. Is like if
I know
if I know I've got Matt NLT gifting me 10 subs every other night,
maybe I go, it's not as good. Actually, it's good. You know,
>> Why shouldn't I accept it? What is the reason that I
shouldn't accept his
I'm not it's not a exchange, right?
In that I'm not providing him any service or any promise or any
action.
>> Like it's not a quid proquo.
Let's go. >> In virtue of what?
>> I'm the opposite. Hey, if you're banned and you want
to be unbanned from something, $5, $15, that's you can always
pay out. Is it wrong for me to
>> Now you guys are Now you guys are in a terrible situation
because I've got all this free time to spend in the Discord,
spend in the community. I can like hang out and do whatever I
want. So, I'm just around to like start timing people out and
collecting my money. How much to free Ozel?
Um
I don't know. I don't Yeah, I don't
We'll see. >> Let the donation or whatever from anyone,
right, >> occur as opposed to why I ought to go in there
and like refund it or ban them or somehow try to prevent the
the donations from happening at all. >> Uh I know you'll
be I know maybe you'll be good Ozel. No, hold on. You say you'll
be good, Ozel. I know you'll eventually threaten to kill somebody
again.
And so it's just like
can I handle that those optics right
I don't know, man. I don't know
But this is further to the point. The point is
>> Ozel is like very similar to Brown is humor except like
way more subtle as in he'll like change his username for a millisecond
or like post a message and then delete it instantly saying something
that he knows that he would get banned for. And he thinks he's
very >> Even putting that aside, if he's not make like
sending me money,
this is poulry amounts. Why would you think my reputation my
uh what what I stand for like my values are worth like such cheap
trifling amounts of money? It's a thousand bucks he gave the
other stream and then I think he gave uh you know over the course
I don't even know if I had to make a guess over the course it's
probably something >> probably g like five grand >> I
don't know 1,800 bucks over the course of the entire time I've
had um monetization which is like less than a
>> Oh really? I would have thought it was like at least
two or three grand. But no, but here's the thing straight away.
Here's Pisco's equation and why
it's like this is all he has to say is I as a
am probably looking at you know in five years like 300 to $500,000
total compensation.
And I know he probably doesn't want to say that to people,
But like I'd say 5 to 10 years he's looking at $300 to $500,000
a year compensation. That's probably what he's looking at as
like a huge lawyer in the most expensive city in the in one of
the biggest most expensive cities in the world. Probably somewhere
in there. Okay. That's like if he had to compromise himself to
do this job, he could just go back to law. Um law law firms like
the ones he worked at, which I'm not going to get specific on,
they don't not take people back. They're not like, "Oh no, you
you up. you like really no like to to get to where he got to
as quickly as he did, there's like something there that people
will pull you back in, right?
So that's what his equation is and he can't really be changed.
And there's also the idea. So there's like short-term, medium-term,
long-term money-m.
Short-term money-making, he could compromise a little bit, but
long-term money-making, you're on YouTube, you've got like connections
to a bunch of big political creators.
You go for the long-term plan of just building out your personality,
your community, your your everything. And you just let people
flock in, right? You let them filter into you.
That's what you do. Okay.
>> what I'm going to for 1,800 bucks doesn't even make
sense. There's not a single thing position I've taken that or
stance I have on anything that is informed by those poulry sums
of money. You know what would make me more money is if I just
read the room
and just gave people what they wanted to hear. >> Oh, this
is the part that I thought was cope where he's like, "Oh, wouldn't
it make me way more money if I just pandered to DG?"
I think you would have to be shortsighted to think that it could
make you shortsighted money. It could make you short-term money.
Um, but I do not think that's a long-term solid game
Like for better or worse, the really intelligent people will
look at someone like like Destiny or that community and they'll
go, "Oh, that's like a total freak show I need to avoid." Right.
Which is the call Pisco just made. Like I can't have these people
be talked about. It's too much.
Yeah. So like you just want to be away from it. So like appealing
to those people just like Yeah. totally cocking to those people.
There is no real long-term money to be made in it. Especially
if you look at it from the point of view of like why did Vos
and Hassan make the same decision about just getting away was
cuz those people are never going to let you be the bigger figure.
Right? Ultimately
trying to make those people happy. Pisco just watched. He just
went through the ritual of trying to make those people happy.
Watching that he observing that he clearly had the better ideas.
He clearly had the more solid position. Nobody could raise a
serious objection. They basically tone policed in a way that
they never apply that standard back on their own community or
the creator they support. It's like, oh, they're just like trying
to correct me or something because they disagree with their creator,
but they can't defend that position why they want to correct
me. They can't defend trying to correct me at all. And then they
can't even defend supporting the other creator in his position
against me. Like, it's it's like embarrassing. Why would you
ever try to Why would you ever try to court an audience that
by definition if you're ever even on even if you're correct,
they will try to tear you down for being correct if it's against
the person they support,
right? Like as much as I know this community can ra like rag
on re sometimes, I love having Really around because he's at
least willing to come in and argue like strenuously like in a
stressful way against
the rolling of the community. my opinion, he's willing to like
stand up on the thing he believes, right? Even if even if I don't
think he's informed, even if I think like, "Oh, I think you're
wrong and I think it's kind of weird that you're even standing."
He'll at least come and do it. And
he won't like I don't need you guys like I'll try to I'll try
to build him up for doing that. Like I don't need you guys to
tear him down. If I think I'm correct, I'll just let my I'll
just try to be correct. I don't want my community to go tear
him down because my ego is too small to admit he might be right.
Like that's stupid. It's gay.
I can't imagine doing that to a friend. Like I think I'm wrong
or I know I'm wrong or I can't muster any argument and then I
try to get my community to go and like tear them down
is nuts. All I hear is DEI hire. How about you? All you hear
is one of the only people with the balls to hop on the stream
when Destiny's threatening to dox people who associate with me.
Do you think about that?
one of the only people who's on that side who would even bother
coming on
>> Okay. Oh well, you say you're joking, but unfortunately
I'm gonna have to stand up business on this and just say it's
like crazy that a lot of people hate on the guy even when he's
wrong. Like I get that he could be wrong.
I get that he could be wrong, but I don't have to like tear him
down. And he's also he's made good points in other conversations.
So again, even if I if like there was a conversation where people
I can't remember which oh the Hassan one about like rapegate
or whatever like I think most people thought he won that conversation.
I didn't go and tell people like [__] this guy. He's
such a piece of [__] I was like oh here's where I
like went wrong in the conversation. I went down like some blind
alley I didn't even really want to talk about cuz I think it
was about the Hila. It was like about the Hila Klein raids into
Ramala thing, right? and I let it go down a different alley.
And it's like, dude, why would I ever tell my community to like
go after Rei because I think he won a debate against me? It would
be like an insane thing to do. I don't know. Or why would I let
it happen?
Be crazy. Anyway, >> you know how I would do really, really,
really well? It's called picking a lane. That's what makes me
a ton of money, obviously, is to not upset members of my own
community with >> Yeah, this is cope. I hope he doesn't
actually think this. that makes you a lot of money in the very
short term.
But I thought I hope he doesn't actually think that's the more
profitable thing because he has he has the right idea. Or maybe
it doesn't matter if he thinks he's following his principles
so that's going to make him the most money or sorry so he's going
to make less money. No, no, no. Following your principles, being
consistent and having a story you can build up over time that
will make you the most amount of money. Okay. By far. not to
some other audience that doesn't like you, that doesn't like
you, and especially doesn't like double doesn't like you if you
disagree with somebody they like more. >> Endless conversations,
six, seven, eight, nine conversations they don't want to hear
>> about a topic that they disagree with me
>> Dude, that was Oh man, that was like the other crazy
thing was I can tell why they got so mad. I got a chance to hear
a little bit. Okay, I got to hear a little bit of
what Queman was saying.
Quean was spitting in the Pisco Discord. He said like 10 sentences
tops over hours,
>> But Pisco's like literally kind of getting like he's
kind of dumbfounded at some point where they're like criticizing
him on tone. They're basically being like, "Yeah, so like you're
sort of right on everything, but like you kind of seem like mean
sometimes." And he's like, "Wait,
you're like destiny orbiters. You're like, you're like Destiny
Orbiters. You're saying I'm being mean. You came into and Quimman
Cunning and he's like, "No, you don't understand, Pisco. These
people only respect strength." Like, actually start telling them
they're morons. Don't do not sit here and pretend that they're
actually listening to the ideas. They only hear strength. They
only respect strength. Tell them they're
so they'll admit they're wrong. And I'm like, "Yes." Like, actually,
actually true. Okay, that's so insanely true right now that these
people they need the tone indicator. They need the alpha tone
indicator. Hey, remember how you're like a total who's not worth
anything and you have to suck up to people who are better than
you because you have nothing to say on your own. Remember that?
You need that tone indicator. Okay, you need that that tone indicator
for people so they can know their place in the hierarchy
like what these people are.
>> It's so it's so annoying, but I was like, "Yeah, that
is exactly what it is.
Yeah, do the tone indicator. It's Oh, but also when you're really
out of place and you try to do the tone indicators like Destiny
does, it's so cringe,
dude. I was talking to Zip Zip and trying to get him to explain
why Pisco was totally wrong in their conversation.
And he's like trying to talk to me. He's like, "You'd know this
if you weren't so stupid." And I'm like, "Yes, I'm very stupid."
Zip Zip, do you want to answer that question? He's like, "Well,
I could answer the question, but you're just like too dumb to
understand." I'm like, "Yeah, I'm too dumb to understand. Could
you break it down for me?" Like like, bro, could you just It's
so funny that they're like, "You're you're so much more dumb
than me." Okay, you could say that. Could you just get to the
actual part of the conversation I care about? I literally don't
care about your opinion. Just tell me what you were saying. My
>> it's not even sensible to think that there's a a financial
motivation here. A because the sums of here like what the Stark
communities,
I don't know how many people follow those accounts.
>> Stark Brookies. >> Is it even close?
I hear they be snarking on cuz you got the money that they don't.
Okay. Broies be snarking on all day to anything that Destiny's
sizes.
>> If I if I truly my only motivation was to make money.
>> So it doesn't make sense on on the on a financial side
and my opinions aren't explained by that. You know, I obviously
gave my opinion on uh the lawsuit and on the the per stuff before
I like was financially benefited from it.
to the extent that I was and I don't think I was. I thought I
was hurt from
Stunts growth, lose subscribers, review
It hurts me on that. Doesn't help me. And so what's the issue?
What is the
>> What is the issue?
>> The issue is I don't even think this is really about
like the argument
regarding my personal incentives.
I don't really think it's about actually making a case that my
opinions are being fed to me.
>> It's about the idea that you're going to say that you
should only hold someone culpable for what you can prove they
did.
That's the true that is the true problem in the liberal fascist
era, okay? Where these these people have totally abandoned, you
know, innocent till proven guilty any form of like, well, you
know, we we know this happened, right? This has been admitted
to, so we can punish this person for this. Right? Here's their
admission. Here's like the evidence. We've we've totally forgotten
that. Nope. Don't need to do that anymore, guys. Guess what?
It came divine revelation. We just get to do whatever we want.
Let's go.
>> Like the, you know, the Spongebob where >> Jesus
Christ. >> Which one was it? They have like something in
their hat. They're getting instructions. Is it the driving test?
And they floor it. >> Okay. With your Spongebob reference.
My god. I forget what it is. What are you >> It's about
feeling.
It's about feelings of people genuinely feeling hurt, feeling
betrayed, feeling sad, angry, >> feeling like things are
unfair. And I believe that a lot of those feelings are sincerely
held.
I I I really do think that a lot of those feelings are sincerely
held. Now,
I hope that people can respect that I have different feelings,
too. I don't express all my feelings that I have out of u for
different reasons that I think are good reasons, but I don't
doubt the sincerity of the people who um who say they like feel
hurt by what I say or um what I'm doing. I don't doubt the sincerity
of those feelings. And I can argue till I'm blue in the face
that they're not right to have those feelings in my opinion.
The feeling, for example, that I'm drifting, I think that that's
not a justified feeling, but or that I'm going to turn into I
don't think that's a justified feeling. Or the feeling that um
I'm actively trying to hurt Destiny. I don't think it's justified
feeling. The feeling that I'm actively trying to encourage my
community, smart community,
I can't
like say that I have any ability to
affect the sincerity of those feelings based on me just dragging
people into voice chat to make arguments. It's not really about
that. And I don't want to claim that I'm the most clear person
whenever I talk and that I have like >> I will say
I do wish at some point I wish I could have talked to Pisco in
the small moment where he was willing to talk about this and
just say I really wish if people were going to say this happened,
you would challenge them or you could because I I feel like getting
him to litigate it, he was somebody who can't be pushed. He's
like too
committed to looking at things from like a legal sense, from
like a like a legal perspective. I just wish I could have gotten
him to look at the whole thing and just see like how they have
literally nothing, like absolutely
that corresponds to why Destiny started doxing people, right?
Destiny started doxing people in like March of 2025.
The first thing he actually has that's tangible in any way I
think
is
I think is the Oh, it's like uh they say we celebrated Rose getting
doxed. Well, I don't think that's true. I think people celebrated
that like Destiny got made to look like a complete by doxing
Rose and proving that she was a minor when he her
through a third party,
right?
And then the next thing is the cyber thing and that's like seven
months later after he doxed like a half dozen people
>> like a a good awareness of
communicating myself well to people who are maybe like just not
they don't know the words I I use many big word instead of few
small word I have plenty of communication issues that are well
in virtue of the fact that sometimes we have issues communicated
or I or me
>> the Kelly Lolena stuff the telling Lolena stuff is like
extremely obviously exculpatory for my community. And now that
Lena is seemingly maybe not that cool with Destiny, maybe she
just explained that like I literally was like, "Hey, it seems
like your partner there is like trying to dox me." She's like, "Yeah,
I know it's really and I just really hope that uh you understand
how much it means to me that you'll like call Kelly out when
she tries to do these like collateral attacks on me."
And then I get Destiny GOING, "THIS GUY TARGETS MY GIRLFRIEND.
THIS GUY targets my And I'm like, "Dude, why don't you ask your
girlfriend what she thinks?" >> Sandy, what is being said?
And I have to have things repeated to me. I'm not perfect on
that score. >> I think we pulled this up already. The rig
doll thing. Hold on. I think it's the rig doll thing. >> What
can I do
if
>> all I do? >> No. Twitter. Buying a plushy of a
does not mean you romanticize, glamorize, or
>> the plushy. >> Two of those genuinely felt feelings
of
>> He retweeted it. I'm sure he did. something immoral.
I'm turning, >> you know, going back on my principles when
I think I'm upholding them, right? If all
guys, it's all me. >> I do. It will never satisfy. I promise.
I promise. So, I could
ban just
any Destiny critic from my discord. I could do that. And in so
doing, would I have acquiesed it um to feelings that I think
are unjustified? No doubt. In some ways, I've already done that.
We'll get to the rule change eventually. I'm a yapper. In some
ways, I've already done that. In response to the previous socialism
conversation, we may adjust the rule basically say, "Hey, let's
keep it focused. Let's not, you know, go too much into personalities."
That's an, you know, that's acquiescing. That's something I wouldn't
otherwise do. Not everyone gets that rule change. We don't do
that for Trump streamers. We don't do that for the average streamer
because I'm sensitive to the feelings. I'm sensitive. There's
a lot of overlap in our audiences. I could
cut off all ties with anyone with whom Destiny doesn't have a
good relationship. I could do >> What? No, don't do that.
>> I could never ever again criticize a position of Destiny's
or not do so in certain ways.
>> I could if I wanted to.
Dude, I like that he's basically he's entirely ruled out the
concept of having like a good faith conversation when he disagrees
with this community or their streamer. Like that's totally gone
out of his mind, right? He's like, "Here are the options I've
got. I tried the good faith way. That clearly failed in every
possible manner. >> Say the words that people want me to
hear and wade into uh a lawsuit on a particular side. I could
I could do that." But there the problem is, hey, it's not going
to satisfy everybody cuz
>> Did you notice that this PC PSA is only happening after
esports Batman and JTO and the rest of the community came and
started talking about H3/Destiny drama?
Oh, that's actually totally wrong, right? That's actually like
a total lie. Like literally, I didn't talk about this drama at
all. Pisco was there for most of the time I was in his VC. I
didn't even speak. I was just listening. I didn't even unmute
my mic to laugh audibly. I just left my mic muted and played
Civ and listen to him tear strips out of Zip Zip like a psychopath.
Okay. Like a psychopathic
wolverine
just like gore. turning this guy into gore
was very interesting, very funny. Okay, >> cuz a lot of
it won't be sincerely done. It's it's done out of fear because
of course the underlying
assertations are not true and people can tell >> Civ 7
>> when you're being sincere and when you're under a gun.
The other problem is I don't want to I don't want to
unless there's a good reason
>> just acquies for its own sake to deal with emotions
at and sincerely held ones genuine emotions. I just feel like
people who say that they're going to dox people in your discord,
people who have doxed a lot of people who are around your community,
former friends of yours, and then they're like, "Actually, your
community is open season 2." I think probably people who are
going to like green light, who are going to co-sign that you
shouldn't have around for the safety of your community,
but hey, and by the way, they do it out in the open. They do
it like directly. Um, it's obvious it's them. And then they go,
"Well, but you let Jay talk here and he doxes people." It's like,
"Okay, evidence. Evidence, please. >> Uh, I'm gonna loop
on this forever. >> I don't have any purchase on what's
actually occurring in my head
>> because if I do that, if I just do it because even when
I think it's >> Queman wasn't even The funny thing is is
like Quimman wasn't even being opportunistic. Queman could have
been way worse in that debate. The thing that I'm sure upset
Zip Zip the most is that when Quimman did talk, from what I heard
when he did talk, it was just to be like to basically try to
explain in a different way, in a rudder way, what Pisco was saying.
And every time he spoke up,
every time Bloomman spoke up, Pisco go, "Yeah, like what exactly
that guy said." Could you imagine a zip zip? You've sat here
just being like this totally spineless loser supporting these
people no matter what they do or say. And then Quimman comes
in the most abrasive, obnoxious
in all of internet commentary.
And Pisco's like, "Oh yeah, I'm vibing with this guy."
Oh. Oh, you could just you could almost feel it.
What good am I? If there are violations of server rules in my
server, we will enforce them strictly. doxing and we'll get into
the rule change eventually. Um,
>> Wait a minute. Sorry. That was his only response. That
was his only response. I can't hear you through your accent.
>> Well, luckily Kisco can hear me to high-five me. Good
luck. >> We will enforce them.
100%.
As we always have strived to do.
Violations of toss the same. What I'm not going to do is be bullied.
>> I It's okay. He's being bullied
into making the decision that's best for him. Okay. I do, but
like h it's like such a I probably shouldn't even quibble on
it, but like that's why Destiny did let his community do that.
That's why he did go and participate. That's why he did go and
litigate the drama that you didn't want litigated there, right?
The only time I litigated stuff in your Discord, and I think
this is another thing that he was kind of responding to was when
I thought you guys were basically saying that this harassment
thing happened. I was just like, "Oh, you guys could provide
evidence if you like."
No evidence exists.
No evidence exists of anything they've like claimed ex anything
that they've claimed exists. Right.
So, oh, also I can go to like Wix Wix Discord and talk about
it now. I think they talk about it a lot too. Adopting
something a position or a standard that isn't based in anything
consistent, any good reason, any justifiable purpose
other than acquiescence and acknowledgement. Now I say that that
said my interests have in fact you know changed in virtue of
recent events
and let me give you an example of this. So obviously we've had
this discussion about the Ethan Klein lawsuit and that has generated
feelings of um negativity that like I'm somehow trying to appeal
to snark communities who generally support
the defendants and the destiny community which generally supports
plaintiff. And it's in that context that that I've had my opinion
and that opinion people have been able to see it develop in real
time from the very beginning when I watched it for the first
time just in because my editor sent me the video and said this
might be interesting. Let's experiment, right? Like you're you're
doing a lot of legal analysis from the Trump perspective. Let's
see if people like it when you talk about these other prominent
lawsuits. So I do so and then the people can see the push back
what I respond to and how I respond to it. Unlike a lot of other
people, I am someone who always wants to hear the and defend
it. and I'm just thinking out loud.
That's one of the I think the secret weapons or whatever that
I I utilize a lot of these conversations. Maybe that's one of
the reasons why I think that's it's more plausible people like
they don't see their chats is because I'm just thinking out loud.
When you hear my thoughts in the nature of a conversation, I
might have some idea about where I want to go generally, but
I'm actually listening to the other side and thinking out loud
and everyone can witness and see in real time. Dude, it's like
it's actually
that
like our our communities, the the snark communities like let
Pisco talk and his they they listen. It's like are there enjoying
like the the the conversation Pisco wants to have and then we
leave and we're like I didn't like Pisco's argument here. And
then
and then the DG attack isn't I didn't like Pisco's argument here.
I didn't like Pisco's argument there. The DG attack is Pisco
is hanging out with Queenman and Jtock in a VC. I guess if he
just wants to be a part of those communities, then he's an evil
now and he's green lit for any attack. It's like uh what about
the arguments, man? What about the argument? Wait, why did you
did you disagree, fam? Like what? Just explicitly
only guilt by association here. Okay, there is no other argument.
Okay,
what kind of what kind of American are you?
What? What are Where are you from? America. Yeah, but like what
kind of America? What's the line from Civil War? What kind of
American are you? Oh, Jesus. This scene's forever. I just want
the line, bro. Can you chill?
>> We're American journalists. >> You told me that
already. >> Okay. We
>> We work for Reuters. >> Reuters doesn't sound
American.
>> It's a news agency. >> I know what Reuters is,
>> sir. Okay. I'm just saying. >> Just saying. Just
what? >> You're American. Okay.
What kind of American are you? Central
>> Uh I thought isn't there like a That can't be it, right?
There's got to be more than that. Is that really the line? I
thought he delivered it differently. Oh well, whatever. Yeah,
I heard I think this movie sucks. I think the movie the concept
was good. I think it sucked completely.
Heard it sucked completely.
Too bad. >> My opinion develop on the Ethan Klein lawsuit.
They can watch it. They're all available.
Every conversation, the hours and hours of people, contrary to
the implication that was being made that I've had no uh exposure
whatsoever to the relevant clips related to the saga, just preposterous.
Everyone here knows that's a lie. Everyone here knows that you
can go back into all my VODs and see people bringing clips to
my attention. can see me spending hours talking about this issue,
dealing with its crit the criticisms at its strongest,
not shying away from it, trying futile, naively, some might say
in the hope perhaps that um either my opinion is adopted or at
least people can say it's a genuine held opinion. Naively saying
reason will prevail and you don't have to agree with my reason,
but naively saying reason will prevail. Maybe if I just
explain myself, maybe if I just get this person to see my logic,
to see what I'm thinking about it, maybe they can at least accept
that we have a disagreement. It's sincerely held naively, innocently,
right? And that's what happened in this last week.
You
I I love Hutch. Hutch is my boy. I respect Hutch. Hutch expressed
he wanted to have this conversation. And I also wanted to have
the conversation. Hutch knows what I'm like. Everyone knows what
I'm like. I'm just thinking out loud. I haven't changed. When
I have these debates, you know, some you catch me in a different
mood, I might feel a little different. Last night on Discord
VC, I was a little bit more chippy and more uh, you know, relaxed
some, you know, doing more jokes.
>> I be so for real right now. Pisco, I I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure this guy had sparked a doobie or something. Okay,
speaking of doobie, this guy sparked a doobie or something before
he got in that car. I He was so happy golucky, laughing his ass
off at everything.
I'm pretty sure this guy was there was something going on there.
Okay, this guy was he was giggling, >> but he knows fundamentally
what this is. >> He was giggling. >> Hutch and I
have these encounters every
Everyone sees it.
This is not some special thing. Everyone knows my demeanor in
these conversations. They know how I talk to Rob No and how I
talk to um
uh you know, different people come on the stream like you know
other examples.
You don't need examples. Even does I when we argue about the
judiciary stuff and what have you. Everyone knows that's how
I am and so does Hutch. And so Hutch is not surprised or maybe
you can tell me. You know, I don't have any basis to think he's
surprised when he walks in the conversation and I act like I
always act.
If anything, I I think I'm I'm trying to be more like trying
to build a foundation. It's why I start where I where I start.
Like, do you care to have this conversation? Do you agree it's
important to have this conversation?
It's me trying to to establish a mutual understanding. And maybe
I didn't do the best at at having that done. I tried. I can tell
you I gave it an honest effort. >> Okay. Okay. Like maybe
Pisco didn't do the best job of like trying to get on the same
page. But the suggestions these dudes had for Pisco were like,
have you thought about just like going down the blind alley and
having that conversation, then going back and redoing it if it
all up? Like just have a conversation about something you don't
care to discuss for like 15 minutes. It's like, dude, get the
out of here. Like actually,
literally go make your own channel. No, you want to have totally
irrelevant conversations for 15 minutes and waste everybody's
time. Shut the [__] up.
>> Okay, but that wasn't sandbagging Hutch.
That wasn't >> Get your dumb ass out of here, man. >> Why
would I want to do that? >> Get your dumb ass over here.
Why would I want to protect a community that isn't my own whose
conduct I don't want to um comment on for reasons because I don't
want to com on the entire thing that everyone should understand
which is reasonable. It's not unreasonable.
Why would I want to protect them specifically? I think the thing
you're getting caught up in that most people are going to be
annoyed about is there's like really egregious
harm being perpetrated by like the person
at the heart of the thing you don't want to talk about. And people
probably want a way to talk about that harm that's being like
consistently doled out without talking about the
And I think that's possible
and it feels like a copout. And I don't like I don't have criticism
for Pisco because literally everybody else is doing this and
it is just the easier way to not catch people's eye and it's
the easier way to not get in like not get into the line of fire
yourself. But like unfortunately I just have to be like no you
actually can discuss the doxing stuff entirely without even having
to reference the case. You can reference the case in the abstract.
You can actually deal with all of the doxing allegations without
the case. And I think it's cope to just let the people who are
perpetually like who just said they're going to greenlight your
server, which I think they'll take back because they realize
they've overstretched. They've like overextended.
But
like that's the behavior that we're all going to pretend we didn't
see.
And I'm just sitting here like I feel like I'm being gas lit
a little bit. I'm just being gas lit a little bit. I feel a little
bit of gaslighting going on. And he could say he doesn't want
to analyze that, but then he's like perfectly willing to talk
to Destiny. And I'm like, well, seems like there's some morally
reprehensible behavior going on. They green lit Pisco. You didn't
see the clip from this morning? Wait, did we not even cover that
clip from this morning?
We covered it with the spider stuff. I guess I just didn't point
it out because I've seen it a couple times already. Give me a
second. Um, give me a second.
Where's I'm looking for a DM. It was this clip. Maybe we didn't
get here with Spider
>> I think we did >> like you or >> At this
point actually I just I don't care what happens to any of these
communities like peace goes included. I think that all you guys
are weird and need to be wiped from the internet. I think it's
all like gotten way out of hand. I'm like at this point I don't
give a [__] about any of it. Like that's just openly
greenlighting the exact same tactics on Pisco. Yeah, we did see
this. I just I don't think I pointed it out. Didn't hit as hard
because I've seen it a couple times anyway. So yeah, they they
did. Super cool. Um, Destiny will take that back because he's
a he's got no balls. He just says these things and then takes
them back.
You guys should you guys should actually do this to Pisco's community,
too. Um, actually, um, no, I misspoke. Didn't misspeak. Lily
upset.
So, I I kind of get why Pisco, but like that's what makes it
feel to me. And he's not, you know, it's not um it's not incumbent
on him to take on that burden of like litigating this at all.
It just feels like he's probably the only person with the balls,
too. And he just opted out. It feels
we're not going to discuss Destiny's drama. Yeah. Well, he's
like actively trying to cut my throat. Actually trying to cut
my community's throat, man.
And in a way that I'm not comfortable fighting back in. I don't
want to do that. I don't want to go there. I'm not going to make
him correct by becoming unhinged and try to do the same [__]
he does. [__] that. >> For like the nothing
money.
>> Why? and [__] up my relationship with my
actual co-hosts for no reason. >> I don't want to do that.
And yet,
in light of an honest agreement among
individuals, among me and Hutch, among perhaps communities of
my own, it gets to that level. No, it's not your actual opinion.
You're lying. Think about that. You're lying. It's not your real
opinion. You don't actually hold to this. In other words, you
are being deceitful consciously. You're leading your audience
to believe a certain thing. And you're doing so because you want
to. You have an
>> Someone just linked me the uh the Wick panel was like,
"Hey, did you see this? Is crazy."
Like, did I see it? I was on >> serious purpose. Had a
serious purpose is to protect a community
>> who was intent on harassing a young
>> who I don't know >> intent on harassing literally
happened months ago. Everybody said it was weird. Don't do that.
And then basically was like, but calling it like harassment threats
is crazy.
Like obviously specifically from somebody applying a standard
that they don't adhere to whatsoever >> based on nothing
but bambi eyed
I addressed the criticism. Okay. Can you explain where you're
getting that opinion from? Anybody you know come on. Not people
from Snark communities,
people from Destiny's community.
This guy DRTZ. Come on. Tell me what I'm >> Oh, here we
go. >> Talk to me. Tell me what is something wrong? What's
what's happening? Do you think I'm lying here? Do you think I'm
being honest?
Endless Discord chats. You can see
what I'm I'm typing. You can follow along. It's all done in the
open.
Endless Twitter DMs. What's your opinion on this? Aren't you
being hypocritical? Responding to them,
taking the time. That's not my actual opinion. My I've always
thought this. Oh, what about this case? Doesn't this case Harper
and Row? It says good faith. So, does that undermine your point
about No, this is why it doesn't do it. running running cases
down where there there was one person who said well here it says
that they said like this was designed to be uh a market substitute.
So clearly design and purpose plays into factor 4. No, because
look at this filing where they're actually analyzing the factor.
Yes, the language appears, you know, that they're taking into
account design and purpose, but that's not actually what the
court found. The court was looking at objective factors there.
And so this is not distinguishing it. This is, you know, the
language is fast and loose. It's speaking about design and purpose
from an objective sense, not from a subjective sense. you know,
so many different objections that have been raised that you guys
don't even know about on threads you guys haven't seen that have
10 viewers. And that was the context of yesterday's conversation.
So yesterday after five hours of talking to you guys just don't
know about the 10 viewer threads on Twitter. Okay. >> Not
a snark. >> Pisco got Pisco got banned you ain't never
heard of, bro. Okay, it's over. >> The head mod of Destiny's
community. He he has an entire effort post. He says, "Pisco,
just be normal. Just be normal when you're encountering normal
people." I read the post. I say, he says, I don't think he'll
talk to me about this. I say, 'Yes, I'll talk to this. I'll talk
with this with you about this. I'll talk to you for and we did
so in front of everybody for 4 hours.
And you can disagree with my approach in that conversation. You
can't say I didn't I don't have the the desire to to actually
sus it out. I could be doing more interesting things
regardless of whether or not, you know, it's necessarily more
money on the margin.
things that I would enjoy more not that I don't enjoy like going
in and now you know I I get some sort of individual enjoyment
out of that in terms of the
>> this guy was about to say he's not a debate that's >> topic
itself it's losing >> like I people could call Pisco a
debate and it's like true Pisco clearly gets off unironically
on believing he's totally correct and everyone like a huge mob
of people want to tell him he's wrong he's clearly never been
happier in his entire life than in those moments
but that doesn't in and of itself make him wrong. In fact, I
believe he's obviously correct in these situations, but like
I like he's supposed to say like I don't get anything out of
well I get a little I do get a little bit out of it now subs
are saying what >> wait which pause frame >> things
that I would enjoy more not that I don't enjoy like going in
and now you know I I get some sort of individual enjoyment out
of that one >> that one was crazy >> things that
I would enjoy more not that I don't enjoy like going and now
and now you know I get some sort of individual enjoyment out
of that in terms of the topic itself it's losing me subs it's
people are saying what the [__] why are you spending
this much time on it it's boring so why am I doing it? Why am
I spending 4 hours talking to the head mod who made this effort
post saying be more normal?
Is it because I'm bad faith? It's in that context. And then there's
a follow-up that night yesterday. So that that conversation happened
like two days ago. Then he messages me
in the Discord and says, you know, these are these are the thoughts
and you know, and I respond to him in text and you guys can all
see the responses in the text. He says, why don't you hop into
a VC? It's like, okay. In the moment, it's 11:00 at night. I
um um this DJ asked Pisco to talk and Pisco said yes. And then
Snarkers hopped in and so Pisco is now best friends with Queen
and Jtock and he's also good friends with Dickers and this is
really dumb. This guy's such a snarker.
See his message. I say sure, pop it to talk to a Destiny mod.
The head mod or at least I think he's head mod. Most important
mod, not a snarker.
Yeah, I just got to go without triggering me again so I can finish
this VOD. Holy [__] >> And we talk. I don't
agree with his opinion. I think it's ridiculous. I think what
he's saying doesn't make any sense. I've always maintained that.
If I was convinced by it, I would say it. I'm not convinced.
I don't find it convincing. I think it's stupid. But I'm engaging
with it because I want to talk to see what am I missing.
Taking it at its strongest.
>> Uh, I'm so glad. Tell me. Tell me somebody was recording
that VC last night when this guy's voice cracked. Okay. I don't
think I've ever heard a more cataclysmous cataclysmic voice crack
than I heard last night from Quean. Okay, that [__]
was crazy.
And then he's going to come out here and try to talk.
Get the out of here.
Need that for the compilation. You have no idea, FP. It was funny
cuz we were checking people who were coming in with like brand
new accounts. We're just like, "Hey, just mic up. Say something
so we know who you are." And then
we voice cracked and I'm just like, dude, I hope somebody was
recording. Actually, I hope somebody's recording this whole conversation
because that can't not have been recorded. That would be disastrous
if we missed that. Dude, I get it. You stream so much. Like my
voice is
Yeah. Yeah, dude. When you stream like eight hours a day, like
literally seven days a week for like weeks on end, eventually
you're using your voice so much that it's just going to start
like breaking. I feel like I'm moments away from
probably never be that bad, but okay. All right. Please from
everybody, >> please finish. I'm like actually so tired
already and I just >> I'm not even tired. Like I got to
go to sleep. It's just like at the end of an eight hour stream
like you're just kind of fried a little bit. I want to go chill.
Can I go chill? >> Loner box. He's not a non debate. He's
a >> Yeah, lonerbox debater. >> And you can take
issue with how that conversation is run. Oh wow. It took this
long because you're doing that. I totally disagree with that.
But you can't say it's motivated by like malice. What do I get
out of that? I'm going to get tea. Um, >> I think I'm exposed
as a as a hypocrite. When you listen to those convers I truly
challenge you to break apart a lot of these conversations and
see who you think is uh trying to >> It's not even my social
battery running dry. Honestly, if I I think Pisco's kind of got
it cased. I like the idea of like getting up streaming for 4
hours and then like doing something else for a little bit, chilling
and then coming back collecting like a little more content and
then doing another four hours. I think Pisco does that quite
a bit where he'll come on in the morning, he'll do like a morning
segment, and then he'll take a break and he'll do an evening
segment. I I really like that idea. I think it's kind of cool.
I'm thinking about it. I'm thinking about doing something like
that to be honest with you. I would have to be getting up way
earlier, right? And then you could just you I think it lets you
create like a cadence where your community is like always active.
>> We'll see. Slow down. >> We'll see. We'll see.
And then also another member members of the community come to
listen to me as it as is their right to do as a member of the
server
right here meaning a privilege as being a member of the server.
You know they are a member of the ser the server in good standing
in that what in that they violate the rules of the server
and so we're an open channel where they're allowed to be not
allowed to record. Okay that's against the rule but they're allowed
to be in the server. They're allowed to be in a Okay, that's
against the rule. Were there a lot of me?
>> I caught this one as we were going by and I was like,
"Okay, that's another one. That's another one
>> The server. >> Good stuff.
>> a VC that was, you know, created for specific all kinds
of crazy faces. You >> addressing concerns from Destiny's
community, from Destiny's top mod. And what what was the response
to that?
What was the response, >> bro? I LIKE I'M LIKE 30 MINUTES
OFF SCHEDULE and you guys freak the out. Thank god that I'm not
entertaining as Fentes. That guy goes like 5 hours off schedule
and people don't complain. Okay. Or they complain but like he
doesn't care anyway. But holy sh I'm like 30 minutes late. You
guys are like this guy can't even keep a schedule. This guy's
the least responsible streamer ever. Mother of God was the response.
Oh look Pisco. You know he's crazy. He's wrong. But at least
he's hearing the argument out. You know, Hobbit messages him
and he's willing to have the conversation. He's not like one
of these cowards who won't.
He's not like one of these cowards who won't have the conversation.
More than I can say for them at 11:00. Not even. >> Why
don't we have the Darius star in here? That's a good question.
Uh, it's cuz I can't delegate other people to Adams and then
I didn't think to add it >> Streaming, right? No financial
motiv. I don't know who the [__] is going to join
the [__] PC. I'm on my phone laying down on my bed
and what was the response to that? >> What was the response?
I need to wake up earlier. >> Taking the time to address
concerns from the Destiny community as expressed by Destiny's
head Reddit mod as expressed by a member in good stand of that
community, Zip Zip. What was the response to that? Was that a
point in my favor? No.
Why was it not a point in my favor? The fact I did that, it was
more evidence against me. Why was it more evidence against me?
Well, because there were snarkers that showed up in the VC. That
proves the point. That proves the point. That proves what we've
been saying. because they showed up in a VC where they have access
to the VC because I where I couldn't have predicted. I did I
ping them? No, I didn't [__] ping them. Maybe someone
told them. I can't control what they [__] DM'd each
other, but they haven't broken server rules. Not that I know
of. Maybe they have. If you bring it to our attention, we will
assess it. But where they have a right to be someone
started violating the rules? Who violated the rules? Whoever
was re I don't even know. We're going to take a look at it. Whoever
was restreaming, someone showed that someone was restreaming
it. That was breaking my rules because there's a rule. We don't
want people to stream the VCs without people knowing about it.
I don't want that to happen. But someone was rereaming it, weren't
they? And I have a suspicion about where that rule breaking came
from. And you do, too. So, what's going on here? So, my rules
don't matter to a community.
I'm specifically in the VC who address concerns from that community,
from people who are in good standing, and who are equipped to
be able to present the arguments in their strongest form. And
because snarkers anti fans are in the VC, I am condemned as myself
a snarker.
An anti-fan. >> Oh, the other stuff I think is at his childhood
home. Simpo. I think that's like his childhood bedroom or something
he was saying. So like that's his old setup or whatever. His
old computer and he's not updating it cuz I don't think he spends
very much time there. So like goes home to and he streams from
there. So it's like a totally different. This is his house or
his apartment condo. Whatever the idea doesn't matter. No VCs.
So, here's the thing.
My VCs are for my community. You want to make content out of
it, there's a streamable VC,
right?
There's a streamable VC. You want to stream something, you want
to record something, you can go to the streamable VC where it's
clear for everybody who's in there that this is live, that you
could be recorded, this is okay to record in here. You go to
like the the community VCs where people having community conversations
and you make content out of it. Keep yourself banned. Get the
[__] out of here. It doesn't matter.
What doesn't matter is this Bambi like naive
approach in which well if we just convince them cuz it's not
about that. It's never been about that. If the situation with
Ethan Klein lawsuit were completely reversed 95% of people's
perspectives would be completely reversed.
Everyone knows it. I can't appeal to anything other than your
gut in this moment. Everyone's positions 95% not mine would be
exactly the opposite.
So it's not about them on my argument. It's not on the specific
question of whether I'm good faith or bad faith. I'm so glad
that Pisco had a conversation with Zip Zip and Zip Zip was such
bad faith in the conversation that it blackpiled him and he's
like actually all of these people are total cultists and they
literally can't they literally can't think for themselves and
if this was done in reverse they'd have the exact opposite opinion
because they are
>> It's not about whether I'm willing to hear the criticism.
>> No, it's obvious DG was recording. DG was openly like
streaming it in DGG >> Spend time specifically to address
it.
It's not about that. Not about what I say. It's >> Stop
BC and you're condemned. >> I'm still >> a terrorist.
Putting aside the absurd >> how's it going? >> Uh,
decent dude. It actually takes so long to get through. I get
like so annoyed at this content.
>> Like going back to like maybe an hour day of day of
this tops cuz I could literally sit here and just like rant angrily
for like 20 minutes every time I stop. Takes forever, dude. >> Yeah.
I I I don't have, you know, I can do I can repeat myself for
the hundth time on the same contradictions
>> a lot of the time.
>> These specific contradictions and this specific drama
at this point I run that
>> you know.
>> Um, a little bit. You're cutting out just a little bit
by the way, but um >> I I need
>> Yep. Um, dude, the uh Oh, I love discussing the like
um
the melancholic situation Zip Zip must have been in where like
you you talk like three times in that VC and each time Zip Zip
got to witness you get something he's never gotten like the streamer
that he loves and adores just being like, "Yeah, that guy that
what that guy just said is correct." Like Pisco not knowing you
and you're like, "Wait, no, what?" He's like, "No, wait. Whatever
that guy that guy who just spoke, that guy was correct. He's
got it." sitting there like never says I've got it.
>> Just argues with me. >> It's like so rough. Uh
>> yeah, I just ordered my um mic. So tell me if I cut
out again a clip or whatever >> No, it sounds about back
to normal. Sounds like how it should be. >> Yeah, cool.
>> Seems that way. >> Sweet, sweet, sweet. >> Of
course it's a screen share.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm about to finish up this Pisco thing.
I'm like at the hour mark of his stream or whatever. I just want
to cover his [__] I think there's like parts of this
that are cope, but they're like not cope in ways that like he's
actually coping and he's like disingenuous.
Like I I think I think what he's doing like banning all this
conversation,
that's probably the highest money-making path he could take long
term, just building around his community. Um because I think
if he tries to engage with the DGers, this just won't work. and
and like they're ba basically he's trying to appease people who
whose sense of right and wrong is just based on what Destiny
says. So whenever Destiny says Pisco's wrong, Pisco would be
wrong to them and they'll never be able to drop it. This is like
not actually worth it. So actually like blocking all of it out
is probably the highest value thing he can do. And yet at the
same time it's kind of annoying because I think that's exactly
why Destiny went and talked about his drama with people in Pisco's
Discord for like four hours last night which we also got blamed
for by the way
>> like basically like why did Jtock and Queen discuss
like Destiny drama and I'm like bro some you mentioned you left
before me and the second someone mentioned Destiny I disconnected
immediately went to my VC and start a VC there.
Yeah,
>> when I was when I was talking. I wasn't bringing up
Destiny, you know, it was sort of like um
>> it was tangentially
involved cuz Pisco was throwing out like little examples and
that that had like little relevance and and
>> but yeah, there was no um there's no like, oh, let's
let's talk about the Destiny drama, guys. Let's let's sit around
and talk about how
>> this guy's a hate him. >> I know you said that.
Zip Zip wanted to hear that he off on car door handles or whatever.
But what he really wanted was people to like try to press him
on Destiny stuff. That's what he wanted more than anything, right?
>> Just say, "Oh, these guys are trauma farmers. They're
just they're just here for drama. They don't care. You just press
them on the pisco conversation then peeled out." Gross. >> Yeah.
I mean, why I didn't join to like um you know,
go and
say, "Oh, isn't Destiny so evil? It was I joined cuz I wanted
to have peace. go talk about
the Ethan Klein stuff, you know, independent of Destiny, cuz
you know, there are some thoughts that
people have that are that are totally independent of
of of Destiny's existence, much to his disappointment, I
>> Yeah. Yeah. I just want Yeah, I just want to chill listen
to that while I was like playing Civ. And I was I was also interested
cuz somebody told me that he was tearing a strip out of Zip Zip
and I was like, "Oh, that sounds funny as let me go hop in there."
>> Yeah. I mean, that that was that was after I've been
in there for a while, I think, by the time someone was telling
you that probably. So,
cuz uh that I didn't quite pick up until a little bit >> Jade
asked, "Is Destiny irrelevant yet?" Um, I mean, it seems like
it's getting there, but also not get I don't know. I don't know.
He seems to spend a lot of his waking hours thinking about how
he can finally wipe out a 400 viewer kick streamer. So, probably
for as long as he's going to have that as his main focus, going
to be difficult to make compelling content. You know what I'm
saying? You know what I'm saying? Give me a play. It looks ridiculous
that anyone can say it out loud. I'm naive enough to thought
to think that anyone ever cared for the standard at all
or a standard or anything. >> Oh, also,
um I'm actively asking people for the recording that voice crack
last night to reply to your fat joke on Twitter. Okay, just so
you know. >> No longer drama related to Ethan Klein
post anywhere
banned. >> No, no, no, no. That was in my Discord. >> Oh,
[__] He kicked us out >> in the server. There
may be and just to out there, there can be occasion potentially
where I might address stuff, you know, if if it comes up, if
for whatever reason, you know, Dan Saltman wants to have a conversation
with me in which the, you know, it's all done and openly on the
live stream. That is the one exception. And then you know you
can chat if it's like responsive to stuff that's going on. But
in terms of the server done and that is
>> Um yeah I was sort of like >> I half watched it.
I was playing games and making food while I watched it but
>> Oh yeah.
Um
yeah I went on there. I was like I have no interest talking to
Destiny.
>> Dude, I'm sorry. I need to
just lay out one t one time on on your stream as well. I did
not dog the Drazzi. I have never dark sell the Drazzi. The argument
for doxing there is incredibly tenuous. It was not on one profile.
It was on three profiles. It was not just on his PayPal. It was
on his Tik Tok and his Instagram as his username. His full name
as his username and his handle as Elder Drazzi on three different
platforms all over the place. no reason to believe it was private
and all people did was make puns with his name and then when
he was upset with it, help him take it down. That's and that's
what everyone's upset about and calling a horrible doxing that
has to follow, you know, anyone that was tangentially related
to Ch's community for
another >> I just three years. >> I feel like all
you got to do is just see how Drazzy feels about it. And it's
like I looked at it as like Drazzie played Street Fighter when
Street Fighter 6 released with like everybody in spicy chat.
I don't think he'd do that with the people who like doxed him
>> take it right back to what happened. He was not upset
about the doxing. That was not what he was upset about. That
is something that Stardust and Wick and these champions. But
fundamentally what he was actually upset about and they fudged
the details because they wanted to jump on this even though he
had said this multiple times and whatever. um was the and then
they used the fact that he said, "Oh yeah, I guess I care about
the doxing." But really they used that to say, "Oh, no, he does
care about the quoteunquote doxing." What he was really what
they he was really upset about was the fact that he had done
or his ex wife and ex-girlfriend who was still his wife at that
point I think had done that he's a polygill um had done photo
shoots together only fans photo shoots together or something
and it was like tagged tagged BBW and we had you know mocked
those and that that's he had liked that stuff on his main account
and all this [__] was like all populated on his main
feeds but that's what he was really upset about was that that
had been mocked. Uh these images have been pulled up and mocked.
Obviously, I won't pull them up or you make huge reference to
them here, but that that is what was really upsetting. He said
that's what upset him and it it wasn't so much
>> and yeah.
So, so I I hate I hate the fact that they constantly still bring
up >> everybody bring that up. >> I don't laugh at
the BBW tag,
>> which you can imagine sort of like how, you know, it's
Elder Drazy's wife with a BB. I just You can't do that on your
main content creator profile and and then be like, you can't
make fun of that, you know, in my opinion. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, dude, I agree with you entirely. I'm just I'm sitting
here. I'm like, "Dude, I we should just move on." I feel I feel
like secondhand embarrassment just hearing about that story.
I'm like, "Dude, that's that's rough. That's Jesus Christ, man."
>> I mean, the other Drazi stories don't get any better,
so I mean Yeah. Yeah. Okay. All right.
Okay. All right. Um,
what else was there? Doobie versus Destiny.
I thought Doobie, Dude, I don't know why. Why would Destiny go
join and like go over these logs? Dude, these logs actually seem
so much worse. >> Made classic error of staking literally
anything on Lauren de Laguna ever.
>> That is the biggest problem. >> I know. >> I
know that conversation.
>> I don't even think like Lauren de Laguna like lies about
everything. I don't think she's like totally insane. I like,
you know, I don't trust anything going on with
cuz she, you know, >> it's the whole I don't trust any
of it. I don't want to, you know, pass through it all. It's impossible.
I don't care.
>> and like
um Destiny unfortunately like you you can not up and Destiny
will make up. It's like if you actually bet it on Lauren de Laguna
and there's a [__] there. It's like yeah, it's
so
this is dude there's like I can't believe Willie Mack let himself
get scoped on this dude. Why do you have saved? And then Desi
responds with multiple reasons why it's okay to save.
And then he's like, "You're absolutely insane for saying that
I have child my
>> When legitimately under 18 when these were taken, so
these are these. What's the object?
>> Yeah, exactly. object. >> If something were to
come out of this, I don't know if um >> the white head
>> if hypothetically her >> her boyfriend or whatever
was actually trafficking or getting other dudes on video for
him for some kind of investigation for like it's other dudes
on video for him. So what are you saying there? You're implying
that these guys could be identified from the material material
you have doing acts and it seems to be cuz that's what you would
want to preserve to be able to prove that these guys are a child
and who they are. You would need you would assumely you're saying
you are keeping
that right. It just it doesn't
>> make any sense to read this in any way other than I
have it right now. That's what that's what every aspect of these
messages reads as. >> And you literally say, "No, that's
not what happened." And there are people
who believe that.
>> bro, there are people in the chat and like not even
Oh, how do I explain it? They're like people in the Wick chat
who are like, "Oh, I didn't even realize you could read it two
ways."
Like, what's the second way? What's the second way? >> Okay.
All right. Yeah, I Doobie almost I thought Dubbie was going to
move on without reading the this page of logs
and he didn't even get to read it very much. Like this is why
I honestly I do believe there's just no reason if you're talking
about Destiny's allegations to have a like real time conversation
with him. I said like I would go >> that's what I've always
said is like you cannot try and argue with Destiny on like his
personal life because he is like so willing to um play the ambiguity
or just make facts up but
yeah it has to be a topic of which there is like perfect knowledge
or at least perfect knowledge to be able to prove
um the claims where even if some contradictory piece of information
was brought up uh that just like totally made up the point still
stands
you know
>> well and I mean I would argue with him like over Twitter
or something. You know what I mean? Like I I think like
as in like I I don't have to sit here.
It's not like it's like when the moment
me. Yeah.
Yeah. where you could just like lay out this and like point it
out and then he would have to actually argue against your whole
argument and it can't be done, right? He knows if you lay out
your whole argument like it's over. There's no you can't make
a counter to >> Oh, it was a whole piece of conversation.
Lally that whole piece of conversation was him desperately trying
to stop Pisco from weighing out any of his arguments in full.
Uh,
dude. Oh, somebody in chat just said even Willie understood in
DMs. Pro understood in the DMs. Possibly just to trigger me because
I'm like, dude, Willie Mack actually let himself get gas lit
into thinking like he might have been wrong here. Like Willie
Mack has no internal monologue. Like somebody was like, "You
just made this up about Destiny." He's like, >> Mac is
about
>> born cattle. He is just born to be, you know,
in in the
in chains. >> It's so crazy >> being, you know, whipped
and picking >> Do not criticize Israel.
>> God. H. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I think we're almost getting to the end
of this Pisco thing. I'm trying to think of Oh, the other thing
I didn't really like is he's like, "Well, I don't want to." He
He has this topic, which is the Pixie case.
>> What's that? You're a You ban him out.
>> I said I'd ban him until I could like uh listen to the
clip. I was like, "Oh, I'll ban him if you feel unsafe. Then
I'm going to go listen to the clip." >> There ain't no
way you listen that clip and you're like, "This guy should be
banned." There is actually zero. There are no way. >> I
let him lay it out, right? >> I let him lay it out and
I'm like, "This is what I heard." And then he was like, "Yeah,
I was really threatening." >> Like he's going to show up
on your doorstep and watch the video and he can't even like say
it. He's like,
He said he was putting together. >> I don't want to say
it because
as if as if like revealed some piece of information and stuff
he was saying his oh. So he said something that clued you into.
It's like no he just doesn't want to say it because it sounds
ridiculous if he gets on stream and says >> yeah I felt
genuinely threatened when this guy said that I'm a and he's going
to show up to my house and show me a video of me a 14year-old
girl. I was really scared when he said that. No you come. Unless
you are literally a
Why would you be scared of that? Why would you think he's being
serious? >> Yeah. No, I It's just one of those things where
the none of these these people are always going to say the thing
they think like hurts you the most, right? Like they it's like
a war to them and they will not be honest. They can lie
as long as they l they feel like their life is basically on the
line. So that they're like they would just do whatever. They
just like you know operate on the same survival mechanism that
the you know hero does. Wild.
All right, one sec. I got to replay it a couple
pig.
>> Dung Devil donated $3. I think the real reason Destiny
didn't hand in the dossier he said he was putting together is
that he was advised not to because he was hoarding so much that
he couldn't not get in trouble for it. Never mind his offer to
fly out to >> messaged me like, "Oh, >> that's not
a bad That's not a bad theory." Yeah. No, but that's not a bad
theory. The guy Dung Devil says that he feels like pro probably
what actually happened is he laid up like a hypothetical for
Andy B where he's like hypothetically if I was holding on to
some stuff some images of a minor. Um should I go to the cops
with them? And Andy B was probably like well hypothetically if
you were warned you could get in a lot of trouble. So hypothetically
you probably shouldn't go to the cops with any of that stuff.
>> I feel like I possible >> um I think they would
probably
>> I don't even think that would happen. Here's my mind
palace interpretation of
He says,
uh, oh, you know, hypothetical, my other stuff. And basically
Andy B will just lay out the law very clearly and say, mitigate
liability to yourself. That's from everything I heard, all lawyers,
everything I looked up at the time of this happening is it would
basically be that because they can't like there's there's a lot
of rules around not being able to, you know, say like delete
evidence, some that, right? So they they just like when there's
like a conflict like that where there could be multiple insecting
things responsibilities to kind of cut against each other and
you could get yourself in trouble. I think they usually say basically
like you know
here here's your situation
and you should do what's best for you. Um,
dude, I I sure hope that like dude, it's so up
that there's a government that would be totally willing to prosecute
this guy on this one on this thing. And Cash Patel is the lead
investigator, the the head of the FBI for sure. >> Yeah,
guys, guys, it's okay. We're getting investigate, guys. Cash
Patel said that he's going to throw the book at this guy. God
damn it.
>> what a world. Yeah, I think and here's the thing. I'm
like at this point based on everything Destiny said, I'm pretty
sure that that that whatever email that got posted on Kiwi Farms
that was basically like here's the group chat that I had. I felt
really uncomfortable told me he had to blow the genitals cuz
why are you doing that? I'm pretty confident he straight up just
threw in that. Like like realistically I'm not going to go claim
that and say like tell other people to do that argument. But
it's like balance of probability >> in the back of my head.
Yeah, the back of my head that's absolutely my heart is there.
That's where my heart is. the fact that he's like never once
um tried to deny it. Like he he literally has confirmed that
the group chat existed, right? That they were trying to find
Rose and he confirmed it after it was first exposed through that
email. >> So I don't know like if there were a law enforcement
body looking into this and they looked through his Discord logs.
Feels like he's basically
I don't understand. You're not hooped at that point, but
you know, it is what it is. I'm not a lawyer. Not a lawyer at
Um, oh yeah, I was going to say moral messaged me after you banned
him um on stream or whatever. And then he he messaged me and
said
"Oh, you know, if you have to ban me, that that's fine.
You have to ban me that's fine. I understand. I make everyone
look bad." He's like the most, you know,
>> why didn't he message?
>> I don't I'm like
your server. He's already server. He was like, "Should I should
I just leave your server? I don't I don't want to make it look
bad.
No, I like I understand the humor he was going for. I'm like,
"Oh yeah, I know exactly like what you'd be talking about here.
I haven't heard it, but like I'm pretty sure he did some crazy."
And then somebody was like, "This is what he said." Like this
is what he said. You think that was serious? And he's like, "Yeah,
I felt really threatened."
>> When we first started, well, when I first started, you
know, talking to War was watching that Vi
where he's like saying VC saying you, you know, what was it?
>> You got
Yeah. Yeah. That was it. Exactly.
It's like what you like, yeah, I understand. I get it. It's a
[__] joke. No one's, you know,
it's only Zip Zip who is even,
you know, plausible that anyone could believe. It's only plausible
that Zip Zip could believe it because that guy is so,
>> you know, literally anyone else. And I feel like >> but
like realistically if we ask Zip Zip so now that you've taken
that position on morale given he has no history of doxing has
never doxed anybody isn't accused of doxing anybody what do you
think of Destiny saying he wants somebody to J and Queenman after
doxing Jtock and Queen or
he doesn't have a position on that. No he doesn't have a position
on that. >> He doesn't Yeah. I guess he's just neutral.
He's just neutral in that one guys. It's like, dude, actually,
>> and the the disingenuous like standard thing, I'm gonna
apply this standard to you that I'd never apply to myself. That's
actually where I'm at. It's like I see it's just every single
time like literally if you if you actually believe this, if you
actually believe was a problem, you wouldn't be watching Destiny.
You wouldn't be capable of having this conversation because you
wouldn't exist in this space right now if you actually had this
problem is so
whatever. All right, I'm gonna try to finish up this video. There's
a soundboard of VC called Mau Grape that is fitting right now.
Well, that is the that is the thing, but it's it's censored,
which is
I wanted to get the uncensored version of it. Me, I'll play it
for people though, so they can hear it.
>> Shut the [__] up.
>> Yeah.
It's not a rule that anyone else,
>> no one else gets that benefit. No one else gets a we
don't talk about their bad rule, but in the interest of at a
bare minimum lowering my level of annoyance having to feel this
my interest, a special little rule for two special little communities.
>> This was good. >> No drama discussion on mine
about those two
streamers. >> If you want to do that, do it somewhere else.
I don't want to see it. I think technically this means that if
somebody accuses me of being a doctor, I still get to litigate
that in Pisco server, >> Why would you want to, man? Why
would you want to? Why do you care to?
>> Why would I want to? Um cuz it the people coming on
my server, the people joining my stream. I like running a collaborative
stream from time to time. >> But you don't get like you're
not, you know, you don't make any progress on that by arguing
in Pisco server. No, I mean I'm probably not going to, but I
will say
basically what I did before when um I think Destiny was trying
to bait me into talking [__] about him to try to
get me banned. I just messaged the mods. I'm like, "Hey, can
I respond to that?" I just accept that uh you know, in the
Jim Crow world that is Pisco Server, I get to use the colored
only. >> It's like being Palestinian, man. It's It's legit
like being Palestinian. It's like so [__] up.
>> Yeah.
Yep.
Different standards for different colors of folks.
It is the way it is. Yeah. Anyway, it's
Oh, boy. >> And with that, folks, we have some content.
We got another like hour so y'all can chill or not. >> He
just leeches the Gondam and Gilmore podcast. God damn.
It's funny teachers are like, "Wow, there's so many Jtock and
Queen people here. Clearly, they try to mind control Pisco when
there's like 95% DGers there.
Um, it started hitting like a point where at least in the YouTube
chat, I think it was getting to like 50/50 for a while.
Um, I'd say the actual Pisco viewers are people who are from
who are more left-leaning and maybe, you know, like that somebody
was being honest about the Ethan lawsuit,
right?
I would say there's a good chunk of like the YouTube chat, some
kick chatters.
So I I don't think it's like crazy there in his discord. It is
a lot of DGs,
but I don't think it's like I don't think it's like crazy to
say that there are some people and I wish because I know a lot
of the names. I I wish people weren't so pushy some of the left
laning people, but they are like a lot of the time. So it is
what it is. What can you
>> Maybe it's not bad to have >> Yeah, you got like
they're like the counterbalance to DG. So, it's like hard to
be too mad about it. Let's just be honest, man. His chat is communist
Marxist Leninist.
That is what the DJers say. Yes, communist Marxist Leninist.
Eh, hold on a second. What is this? I should get sent a picture.
Probably a correct comment. Okay, we'll see where it goes. I'd
say right off the bat, it looks correct. Mr. Girl, continual
vindication.
Destiny centering the attention towards Pisco's community and
how Pisco has to moderate. ban everyone who doesn't like Destiny
and voices it from the chat and constantly said you only think
this because of obsessive crazy bad actors in your like Jtock
Queen Aaron and Doobie and how he has to cut those people off.
This is the same tactics Mr. Girl called out years ago. If any
portion of vas of a vassal community of destinies starts to garner
any amount of people that don't like him, he has to give the
that orbiter the talk where he undermines their ability to think
for themselves, loads them with talking points, and tries to
convince them that everyone and anyone leveraging any criticism
about him are crazy, insane, bad faith actors, and that none
of the critiques/reasons to not like him are true and are completely
BS. critical element here are certain people, certain talentless
hack losers like counterpoints in Arerodite who will do this
and pretend, oh, I'm just like a nice person who, you know, I
get to have private conversations with Destiny. He's actually
really nice. And this JTO guy lies about him and he lies about
me and he lies about everybody and he's like the worst and you
just should just believe me and I'm just like woo I'm just like
a little old I I just couldn't possibly defend myself.
Very important to have the good cop bad cop elements there. Okay,
critical. In fact, how am I figuring this out? Um, mostly, you
know, schizosphere tap in, but it it has happened guaranteed.
I know Pisco will watch this VOD as he watched the previous VOD
and he will understand this. He'll he'll know what I'm talking
about. When when they come to you and they're like, "This Jtock
guy is actually evil. Have you heard the he said about me? Have
you have you seen He's like threatened me. He's like threatened
my family. Like we got doxed." I know this has happened. I promise
you this happened. Okay, Pisco, just ask for evidence of any
of it. anything that attributes it to me, please
in the future when it does
Anyway, I think we finished with the Pisco stuff. I That was
all the content I was going to do today. I could do more [__]
but I'm probably going to hop off and uh I don't know, chill
for a little bit. I might hop in the Discord a little bit. We'll
see. Getting a little late, but we'll we'll see what's going
on. Could hop in the Discord, check some stuff out. All right,
stream. Be back tomorrow, I believe. Yeah. Yeah, I'll be back
tomorrow. Yeah, I don't know what I'm doing for Christmas. I'm
like going home. I don't know if I'm going to take my laptop
and stream. If I want to take my laptop and stream, I have to
like start setting my laptop up now. So, maybe I'll just do that.
I'll set my laptop up to stream and I'll go stream like a day
or two from home because I won't I won't have to My parents will
be tired and shoot anyway. All right. All right. Let's see. Nobody's
really online. I'm just gonna end. See you guys later. Have a
good night, everybody. Bye-bye.